[Musique]
Bonsoir.
Bonsoir
Jean Dicla reoir.
Nous vous recevons ce soir pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
D'abord merci de l'invitation. C'est un
grand honneur de pouvoir discuter avec
vous ici dans ce beau studio.
Je suis un homme très banal. Je suis
citoyen de la République de Genève. J'ai
été pendant très longtemps professeur de
sociologie euh à l'université de Genève
et dans d'autres universités aussi.
Depuis 20 ans, je suis aux
Nations-Unies, d'abord comme rapporteur
spécial sur le droit à l'alimentation
pendant 8 ans et maintenant je suis
vice-président du comité consultatif du
Conseil des droits de l'homme des
Nations- Unies et surtout auteur de ce
livre, le capitalisme, expliqué à ma
petite fille en espérant qu'elle enverra
la fin. Et voilà.
Euh, on va commencer par les réfugiés.
Oui. Euh, on va commencer par les
centres de rétention administratif.
Oui.
On va ensuite enchaîner sur est-ce qu'il
faut détruire le capitalisme
et comment
et et puis on va avoir plusieurs
plusieurs fois la capacité de d'aborder
certains sujets,
surtout la fin dans le monde qui est un
massacre effroyable.
Pourquoi la fin la fin dans le monde
c'est un massacre effroyable ? Est-ce
queon pourrait on pourrait sauver ça ?
Tous les 5 secondes un enfant en dessous
de 10 ans meurt de faim ou de ses suite
immédiates. C'est les chiffre de la FAO
de l'Organisation spécialisée des
Nations Unies sur l'alimentation et
l'agriculture.
Et le même world food report de la FAO
qui donne des chiffres des victimes qui
sont constat contestés par personne
chaque mois d'avril. Le M Food Report la
FO dit que l'agriculture mondiale telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui pourrait nourrir
normalement 12 milliards d'êtres
humains. C'est-à-dire le double nous
sommes 7,3 milliards d'êtres humains.
Pratiquement le double de l'humanité
pourrait être nourriement
si euh
ce n'était pas le pouvoir d'achat qui
détermine l'accès à la nourriture, mais
s'il avait un ordre du monde normatif
qui assure la réalisation du droit à
l'alimentation pour chacun des 7 8
milliards d'étates humains. Ça se passe
pas.
Est-ce fait est-ce que c'est fait à
dessin de laisser crever les pauvres ?
Oui, à dessin pas une intentionnalité.
Je pense pas que les maîtres du monde se
lèvent le matin.
Je je devrais m'expliquer ce qui sont
les maîtres du monde tout à l'heure que
ces oligarchies qui règnent sur la
planète les maîtres du monde se lèvent
tous les matins disent aujourd'hui je
vais faire mourir tant d'enfants de
femme d'enfants par la privation de
nourriture par exemple. Euh je pense
pas. C'est un ordre du monde cannibal
qui a été instauré.
par les oligarchies du capital financier
globalisé qui surdéterminent
euh les état les plus puissants du
monde. Dans mon livre, je donne un
certain nombre d'exemples de la
dictature, comment elle fonctionne face
au face au gouvernement du monde,
peut-être pour pour les peut-être pour
les cerner de plus près ces maîtres du
monde qui gouvernent cette planète. Je
prends je veux pas vous ennuyer avec
trop de statistiques ce soir. Non non,
les professeurs font toujours cette
erreur là. Mais
euh à être de la Banque mondiale de
l'année dernière, les 500 plus grandes
sociétés transcontinental privée,
tout secteur confondu, banque, services,
industrie et cetera, les 500 plus
grandes sociétés transcontent privé ont
contrôlé l'année dernière 52,8 % du
produit mondial brut, c'est-à-dire de
toutes les richesses produites en une
année sur la planète. Ces sociétés
transcontinentales, ces oligarchies qui
les gouvernent ont un pouvoir comme
jamais un roi, jamais un empereur,
jamais un pape eu dans l'histoire de
l'humanité. Elles échappent à toute
forme de contrôle social, étatique,
interétatique, syndical, parlementaire.
Elle sa faire, ça je le dis tout de
suite, énormément de choses. Le mode de
production capitaliste est certainement
le mode de production le plus créateur,
le plus inventif, le plus dynamique que
l'humanité est connue jusqu'à maintenant
dans la chimie paroise. Euh il a un
nouveau molécule, un nouveau médicament
qui né tous les 3 mois. Des milliers de
satellites tournent dans l'atmosphère.
un fonctionnaire de l'Union de banque
suisse de qui sont des bandits de à
Zuric correspond avec la sucursale de
l'USBS à Tokyo
avec la vitesse de la lumière 300000 km
par seconde.
Euh
il a une incroyable et je peux le
multiplier les exemples, tous les
pourqui
la la succession des des des révolutions
scientifiques,
technologiqu électronique. On a en
sociologie, on appelle ça le savoir
problématique est gouverné est gouverné
par ces oligarchies là. Elles ont
produit euh une abondance incroyable
pour quelques-uns, mais en même temps en
même temps
en même temps un ordre cannibal du
monde, on a pris la fin, je pourrais
prendre d'autres exemples. La fin tous
les 5 secondes d'un enfant sous de 10
ans meurt de faim alors que 12 milliards
le double de l'humanité pourrait être
nourri. Normalement, un enfant qui meurt
de faim maintenant où nous parlons et
avant qu'on est terminé, il aura
simpement beaucoup d'enfants, être
assassiné. Il y a aucune quelconque
fatalité. Il l'a eu il y a des siècles,
il n'a plus aucune un enfant qui meurt
de faim maintenant, nous parlons est
assassiné. 2 milliards d'êtres humains
n'ont pas accès régulier à l'eau potable
non nocif. Tous les 4 minutes, quelqu'un
perd la vue par manque de vitamina. Et
dans les pays de l'hémisphère sud où
vivent les 3/4 de l'humanité,
les épidémies depuis très longtemps
vaincues par la médecine font des
millions et des millions et des millions
de morts
tous les
tous les sens simplement que les gens
puissent pas peuvent pas se payer
les quelques euros pour avoir accès au
médicament. C'est bien un ordre
cannibal.
deire d'eau si tu veux boire un peu
d'eau. Oui. Pourquoi on narrive pas à
réguler cette finance ? Parce que les
États n'ont pas envie, ne peuvent pas,
parce que les Nations- Unies peuvent
rien faire non plus.
Ah, les Nations Unies sont paralysées
pour d'autres raisons. On peut en parler
tout à l'heure.
On peut commencer par ça. Pourquoi elles
sont paralysées Je dis
pourquoi cet ordre cannibal du monde,
cette dictature planétaire
des oligarchies très réduit de la de la
du capital financier globalisté. Je
prends rapidement entre parenthèses, un
autre exemple qui est frappant.
Oxfam le rapport décembre dernier 2018
dit que les 36 milliardaires les plus
riches du monde ont eu autant de fortune
l'année dernière que 4,7 milliards
d'êtres humains. C'est-à-dire que la
partie la moitié la plus pauvre de
l'humanité. Pourquoi cette normalité ?
Pourquoi cette acceptation alors qu'il
n'a pas d'impuissance en démocratie
alors que nous sommes informés ?
Pourquoi ? Alors les raisons sont
multiples. D'une part, ces oligarchies
ont produit une
théorie de la légitimité qui bétonne la
conscience collective. Mon ami Pierre
Bourdieu les a appelé
appelé le néolibéralisme le
l'obscurantisme le plus dangereux qui
existé sur cette planète et qui dit
qu'il a une seule instance régulatrice
c'est le marché mondial la main
invisible du marché mondial que les
forces du marché fonctionnent selon des
lois naturell que donc l'homme tout ce
qu'il peut faire puisqu'il est expulsé
de sa propre histoire et les gr sociales
et l'homme comme individu
Tout ce que l'on peut faire, c'est de se
soumettre, de devenir fonctionnel
de ce marché
invisible, naturel. Naturel. Alors,
c'est le nouvel esclavagisme.
Non, c'est trop simple de dire, je
m'excuse, je te
C'est une question internet. Le
capitalisme est-elle une forme
économique de l'esclavagisme ?
Bah, bien sûr, mais beaucoup plus
raffiné, beaucoup plus généralisé. La
société esclavagiste a été limitée dans
le temps, trop longtemps, 350 ans
commerce des déportations Atlantique
Sud, Atlantique Nord. La société
esclavagiste a disparu en tant que type
de société très récemment. 1888, c'est
le Brésil qui était le dernier pays à
appoli, la princesse Isabelle, le fameux
décret 188,
c'est avantier.
Mais le capitalisme a créé une société
d'oppression, de destruction.
Pourquoi on peut pas
pour le planète et pour les hommes
infiniment plus efficace et
planétairement répandu.
Pourquoi on peut pas le réguler ?
D'une part ? Parce que le
néolibéralisme,
bon je je vais aller un peu plus loin.
Chacun être humain qui né sur terre né
avec une conscience de l'identité. Moi,
je suis l'autre, l'autre et moi de
l'identité. Quand un chien voit un autre
chien qui est battu, rien ne se passe.
Quand un homme, quelle que soit la
couleur de sa peau, son affiliation
politique, philosophique, religieuse et
cetera, son âge, quand un homme voit un
enfant devant lui qui est martyrisé,
quelque chose en lui s'effondre
puisqu'il reconnaît, il se reconnaît
automatiquement immédiatement dans
l'autre. Donc la conscience de
l'identité,
c'est de l'empathie plutôt, non ?
Bah c'est un mot faible, l'empathie
conscience de l'identité.
Question de Clément Rine
qui toi
Clément Ren dit c'est de l'empathie,
c'est pas de l'identité.
Bon moi je dis bah il faut lire mon
livre dans une p enfin je dis je me suis
donné la peine d'argumenter et le livre
le capitalisme explique à ma petite
fille en l'espérant qu'elle a ver à la
fin pourquoi il faut le détruire. Bah,
on y viendra parce qu'il faut le
détruire avant qu'il nous détruisent et
détruisent sa planète et les gosses pas
centaines de milliers peut nous détruire
le capitalisme il peut nous détruire
comment ?
Bah il est en train de le faire s'il est
le massacre de la fin n'est pas la
destruction d'êtres humains comme vous
et moi ceux qui nous séparent des
victimes. C'est uniquement le hasard de
la naissance.
Vous êtes blanc, intellectuel blanc,
parien, succès, homme des des médias
fêtés et cetera et cetera.
Vous n'êtes pas un coup de canne à sucre
au nord-est du Brésil où vous auriez la
moitié de la tente de vie que vous avez
ici, 47 ans que vous avez le verr,
l'angoisse du lendemain parce que vous
savez pas comment vous allez nous. Or,
par hasard, par hasard, vous êtes cet
intellectuel blanc parisien.
Les Nations les Nations les Nations
Unies, elles font quoi ?
Non, attends, tu tu me couves trop vite
là. Non, j'ai
mon petitfils, il s'appelle Théo, qui
est une merveille absolue.
Euh,
auditeur passionné de vos émissions.
Et bien
au moment où il n arrive sur cette
planète, il est il a cette conscience de
l'identité
et cette conscience de l'identité qui
devrait conduire à un monde de relation,
de solidarité, de réciprocité, de
complémentalité, moi je suis l'autre,
l'autre et moi, a été bétonné, a été
ravagé par l'obscurantisme néolibéral,
je le répète, qui veut nous faire croire
et qui domine les médias et qui a les
moyens de nous faire croire et qui nous
fait croire effectivement que
il y a une seule instance régulatrice
qui fait l'histoire, c'est le marché et
que les forces du marché obéissent à des
lois naturelles. C'est comme les forces
naturelles comme les champs magnétiques,
comme les circuits des astres et cetera
et cetera. Alors
ce qui détruit et étouffe cette
conscience de l'identité or elle renaît.
C'est pour ça Carl Marx a dit une chose
magnifique dans une lettre à à Vma son
ami Joseph Ma révolutionnaire doit être
capable d'entendre pousser l'herbe
d'entendre pousser l'herbe. Et bien
maintenant cette conscience de
l'identité renaît à travers la société
civile, à travers les gilets jaunes, à
travers les centaines de milliers
d'adultes de d'adolescences de de de
d'enfants qui tous les vendredis depuis
le 15 mars remplissent les rues même à
Genève. Vous imaginez ?
Ils étaient 10000 vendredi dernier pour
témoigner de leur révolte pour exiger
les états qu'il brise les mains de ces
de ces oligarques et qu'il préserve
qu'il préserve la planète de la
destruction qui est en cours à cause du
système capitaliste qui est en cours
maintenant. Vous savez que la conférence
de Paris la COP à 2015 il y a il y a 4
il y a 4 ans, un peu moins de 4 ans
a fixé comme limite extrême
euh la norme suivante à la jusqu'à la
fin du siècle. Le climat doit se
réchauffer au peut se réchauffer au
maximum de 1,5°gr.
Et si c'est plus et bien c'est la
désertification, les famines, la les
océans qui montent. Il n'aura plus de
Marseille ni de New York, ni de
Hambourg, ni de Porto. Les portules vont
disparaître. Les les les villes euh
portuaires vont vont vont disparaître.
C'est dommage parce que 80 % de la
population est basée sur les côtes.
Oui. En plus on est confronté et
pour vous montrer pour vous montrer le
le système destructeur du capitalisme
que les jeunes ont compris, il y a un
chapitre 5 dans le dans l'accord de
Paris qui a quand même été signé par 190
États du monde. C'est quand même pas mal
en fait. Et il y a un chapitre 5 qui est
pillon pétroleum au-delà du pétrole.
Au-delà du pétrole. Et euh là, il est
dit que les États doivent obtenir des
géants producteurs du pétrole
une réduction de 50 % de leur production
jusque en l'an 2030 puisque le CO2
expulsé dans l'atmosphère vient pour 80
% 80 % de l'énergie fossile de gaz,
pétrole et cetera et cetera que les
géants du pétrole doivent réduire de 30
% et de de de de 50 % leur production et
donc l'expulsion du CO2 dans
l'atmosphère. Et une deuxième
deè deuxème impératif qui été imposé au
pétroli c'est de dire c'est dire que 45
% du revenu net doivent être dès
maintenant accè
investi accordé
dans l'investissement au développement
des énergies alternatives hydraulique
solaire et cetera et cetera. Or
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans les 4 ans
depuis Paris ?
Les plus grandes sociétés pétrolières,
les cinq plus grandes qui ont 85 % de la
production et du forage et du commerce,
les cinq plus grands ont en moyenne
pratiquement doublé leur production.
pratiquement double vou de production
et de
le revenu net, le profil net qui sont
généré, ils sont accordés, ils ont
investis dans le développement des
énergies alternatives 5 % au lieu de 45
%. Ce qui montre bien que les États,
même les plus démocratiques, même les
plus puissants économiquement,
politiquement n'ont aucune prise sur les
olhargies du capitalisme mondialisé.
Donc on peut pas réguler le capitalisme.
Mais comment il faut le détruire ? C'est
ça que je dis.
Alors on détruit, vous savez,
il faut passer par un effondrement pour
le détruire.
Je dis en
mon livre
euh qui est sorti d'abord en français
bien sûr et elle été traduite en dans 14
langues jusqu'à maintenant et je fais le
plus possible de conférences de
conférences si mon travail en Nations
Unies me laisse le temps ce qui est
malheureusement assez limité et chaque
fois quelqu'un au fond de la salle à
Madrid à Berlin et cetera là ou ou
récemment Grenoble, l'inflam, il dit
"Puisque vous dites que le capitalisme
est tellement inventif, tellement
créateur de richesse d'un tel dynamisme,
pourquoi il ne suffirait pas de
réformer, d'humaniser
ce ce capitalisme, de le réguler ? Or,
c'est c'est totalement impossible parce
que le capitalisme fonctionne par une
seule stratégie, la maximalisation du
profit
à n'importe quel prix humain et dans le
temps le plus court. Et le problème
pétrolier par c'est dans l'actualité
immédiate vous vous le prouve vous le
prouve
comme tous les systèmes d'oppression
dans l'humanité qui se sont succédés
aucun n'a pu être réformé. humanisé,
amendé, amélioré. aucun les
révolutionnaires, enfin les ouvriers euh
et artisans du du
fauble Saint-Martin du fauble
Saint-Antoine qui le matin du 14 juillet
euh ont marché sur la Bastie pour
prendre le la poudre
la la forteresse et la prison des
prisonniers politiques du roi. et bien
ils avaient de la peine puisque 10 m de
les fosses des fosses d'eau 10 m 30 m
hauteur des des murs de l'on le le
gouverneur a tout de suite levé le le
pont levi que dans l'après-midi
seulement que quelqu'un on sait pas qui
des insensés a eu l'idée d'appeler
la faillette d'appeler la faillette dit
là il y a Versailles avec Euh milchoise,
il a un général qui a lutté contre autre
roi avec d'autres insurgés donc avec
contre le roi d'Angleterre avec avec les
insurgés de Washington. On va l'appeler
et on a envoyé des gens pour chercher la
faillette. Il n'est pas venu lui-même
mais il a envoyé les fameux deux
bataillons avec les h canaux qui ont été
dirigés sur le le pont Levi de l'ON
gouverneur baisser le pont lev espérant
de négocier le peuple de Paris est entré
dans la pastie a massacrer un peu le
gouverneur mais à libérer les
prisonniers a pris des armes et cetera
et cetera
et bien on ne pouvait pas et ensuite le
processus révolutionnel français s'est
déclenché jusqu'à la première les
Républiques 83 jusqu'à l'exécution du
roi jusqu'à
on l'a pas réformé, on l'a fait tomber.
On l' fait tomber mais c'est pour vous
répondre parce que mais non mais c'est
c'est essentiel le féodalisme on pouvait
pas l'améliorer la monarchie il faut
détruire non je la société non la
société esclavagiste par exemple bah on
pouvait pas la réformer l'humaniser le
colonialisme on pouvait pas le rendre
moins oppressif moins moins de torture
moins d'expoliation les les jeunes
algériens les quelques cet avant
qui le 1er novembre 54 ont pris les
armes et ont contesté ont attaqué le
système colonel français et bien 7 ans
plus tard et 2 millions de victimes plus
tard blessé déporté et cetera plus tard
juin 62
7 ans plus tard et bien la République
algérienne souveraine indépendante est
née on pouvait pas aménager humaniser le
colonisme la discrimination des femmes
qui continuent
On peut pas la l'améliorer un tout petit
peu ou bien la femme est l'égale de
l'homme ou elle l'est pas juridiquement,
affectivement,
socialement. On peut aucun des systèmes
d'oppression qui se sont succédés dans
l'histoire de l'humanité n'a pu être
amélioré, humanisé,
réformé. Même chose pour le capitalisme,
beaucoup plus fortement pour le
capitalisme qui est en train de détruire
la planète. J'ai dit l'exemple pour
et te faire mourir tes enfants de faim
et te rendre'estce
humilié tes
je suis d'accord avec personn
non alors vous êtes ou pas
je suis d'accord
bah alors c'est tardif c'est écoute
on peut détruire
merci
qu'est-ce qui se passe si le capitalisme
se vautre si le capitalisme si le
système financier euh on va dire fait
nous fait un malaise s'il y a un effet
domino sur C'est un effondrement.
C'est un effondrement. Voilà. Qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? l' déjà plusieur
Bon, c'est une question importante euh
mais euh
je reprends la Révolution française.
Vas-y,
je reprends non pour pour bien montrer
on a tout notre temps.
Les insurgés
du 14 juillet qui ont pris la bastie
ouvrir artisan parce qu'ils veulent
libérer leurs copains, ils avaient
besoin d'armes et cetera et cetera.
Bah si le soir sur les qu de la scène,
il avait eu un journaliste français de
Seview
qui aurait pris un insurgé par le veston
qui lui aurait dit
qui lui aurait dit citoyen du pont.
Maintenant, expliquez-moi quel est le
texte exact de la constitution de la
première de la première République
française ou quel est le texte exact de
la déclaration du champ de Mars
séparation église état ? Dites-moi, on
voit bien c'est absurde. Le chemin se
fait en marchant. C'est le mystère de la
liberté libéré dans l'homme qui dira
qu'elles seront les nouvelles
institutions, qu'elles seront le nouveau
cont qui ça pas.
Tu te mouilles pas trop là.
Non, attends, je te donne un exemple. Un
autre exemple. Est-ce que tu es tu veux
pas comprendre ? Pas comprendre.
Euh
septembre 39,
Barcelone en flamme franco les
fascistes, les nazis cagolin
Hitler et Franco C. Et sur le perdu vers
l'exile euh
français, vers Toulouse et cetera et
ailleurs euh il y a le cortège
des éclopés, enfin les les
révolutionnaires blessés,
ensanglanté et cetera et cetera, boîte
et tout ça qui marche. Et parmi un jeune
type qui s'appelle Antonio Machado, le
célèbre maintenant célèbre Antonio
Machado, qui s'y flotte
qui so qui semble joyeux et ses
camarades lui disent qu'il marche avec
lui qu'Anton T fou
Barcelone brûle la dernière ville notre
ville brûle nous avons perdu des
milliers des milliers de camarades
hommes et femmes dans la lutte contre
contre le fascisme. Nous allons vers un
exile totalement incertain et toi tu
sembles tout content. Et c'est là où né
ce poème extraordinaire qui est
mondialement célèbre. Caminante camino
et camino c'est assez à l'endar
et cetera et cetera. Homme qui marche il
n'y a pas de chemin. Le chemin ce sont
des pas qui le font.
L'important c'est pas la destination. Ta
question il y a une seule réponse tout
processus révolutionnel et comment il
arrive comme de déclenchement ça il
faudrait en parler tout à l'heure le
déclenchement du processus
révolutionnel.
Son développement est totalement
imprévisible. Ce qui est certain que
nous portons nous maintenant, toi et
moi, l'utopie du monde tout aute.
C'est dommage, tu n'as pas fait la
sociologie, tu as pas eu ce bonheur.
Euh, tu es un pur génie mathématique.
Euh, il y a l'école de Francfort,
Horkaim, Marcus,
Benjamin, enfin qui s'est suicidé au
Pyréné, au passage du Péné. Euh les
sociologues, les vieux marxistes
allemands de l'école de Francfort disent
une chose très juste. Chacun de nous mit
une double histoire.
D'une part, la justice empiriquement
vérifiable, la justice telle qu'elle
est, elle est effroyablement
régressif aujourd'hui. La Syrie depuis
massacre boucherie effroyable. personne
n'in pas un casque bleu, pas un corridor
humanitaire, rien du tout. Il y a le
Darfour, il y a le Yémen, je suis dans
la commission d'enquête
du Yémen du Conseil des trois totalement
effroyable où le drame des réfugiés, je
reviens de l'espace du hotspot où des
enfants de moins de 10 ans enfermés avec
une nourriture
imangeable derrière les les derrière les
barbet. Peut-être on peut en parler plus
en en détail. euh
stratégie de l'Union européenne et créer
les froids et cetera pour bon. Bref,
cette
justice
empire tel qu'il est vécu effectivement
aujourd'hui est effroyablement
régressif. Mais en même temps, chacun de
nous vit une deuxième histoire,
l'eschatologie comme dit Adorno, c'est
la justice exigible, ce que ma
conscience
exige pour être juste et qui est cette
utopie qui nous habite de du tout autre.
Utopie c'est pas un rêve toujours.
L'utopie c'est une force historique.
Cette conscience,
il faudrait parler en allemand mais
c'est personne ne comprendrait parce
qu'en allemand c'est beaucoup plus
clair.
La conscience celle-là elle augmente
tout le temps. Je peux donner des
exemples. Je prends un exemple pour pas
été trop long. J'étais pendant 8 ans
rapporteur spécial du droit à
l'alimentation. Le premier Kofian m'a
nommé mon ami, il est mort maintenant.
C'est un homme tout à fait exceptionnel.
Cofian, tout à fait formidable,
exceptionnel.
En ce qui concerne les familles dans le
monde, les destructions par la fin, il
avait une théorie totalement dominante,
le maltusianisme.
Ce pasteur Thomas Maltus, pasteur
effroyable, nazi de la fin du 18e siècle
dans un livre célèbre qui s'appelle
Essay on population grows a produit une
théorie qui a servi magnifiquement
évidemment les élites dirigeantes du
monde colonial anglaise, français et
cetera. Et là, il dit
mourir de la fin de de de la fin de la
misère et cetera, du m C'est horrible
mais c'est nécessaire.
Dieu l'a voulu parce que s'il n'y avait
pas cette élimination
par la misère par la fin de tant de
temps de millions par an, plus personne
bientôt ne pourrait sur ces planètes
manger, boire, respirer. Donc la
destruction des êtres humains par la fin
comme une sorte comme une sorte comme
une nécessité finalement voulue par
Dieu. C'est Thomas Altus
jusqu'il y a 30 ans en arrière. Ces
théories étaient totalement dominantes.
Totalement dominante.
Aujourd'hui, même l'amb moi j'ai vécu
des ambassadis de l' des ambassadeurs
américains
assez effroyables. s pass de Bush par
exemple multimilliardaire, je dis pas
son nom parce que j'ai eu assez de
procès sur le dos déjà le
multimilliardaire
américain qui était l'assur de bouche
même les plus effroyablement
réactionnair
euh n'ose plus invoquer la théorie
maluscienne plus personne alors qu'elle
était totalement présente comme argument
recevable pour expliquer le massacre de
la fin tant les églises tant les
universités dans les institutions
internationales, c'est fini. Plus
personne par sa conscience collective a
fait un saut caritatif. La ligne de
flottaison de la civilisation augmenté a
augmenté.
Euh
l'esclavage a été justifié par des
théories multiples, racistes,
effroyables.
La discrimination des femmes au 19e
siècle. Il y a des philosophes français
en plein Paris qui ont discuté pour
savoir si les femmes avaient une âme.
Donc
tous ces Mais non, tu rigoles mais ça ça
crée une missile effroyable.
Après il y a des médecins qui ont
inventé qu'il fallait les traiter contre
l'hystérie. Ils avaient des méthodes un
peu bien spéciales.
Horri horrible.
uniquement ces exemples, je les donne
pour montrer que cette deuxème histoire
que nous vivons, c'est de la
conscienceugée
de l'utopie qui nous habite, elle
progresse et donne lieu à cet optimisme
formel, cette espérance qui m'habite
dont on peut parler mon livre le
capitalisme expliqué à ma petite fille
en espérant qu'elle envoyera la fin et
nourri sans cette espérance, je l'ai pas
écrit
ce livre. Alors, il reste le problème
difficile
ce que Jean-Paul Sartre a a dit a nommé
l'incarnation. L'incarnation,
c'est un nom peut l'incarnation, c'est
Jean-Paul Sart.
C'est la question à quelle condition
une idée devient-elle force sociale ? À
quelle condition cette utopie que nous
portons nous devient-elle conscience
collective transparente ? devient-elle
force historique matérielle
modificatrice de réalité ?
Tout ce qu'on peut savoir, c'est ce que
ça s'est passé tout le temps dans
l'histoire d'une façon répétée.
L'incarnation a eu lieu. Je peux pas te
dire quand et où elle aura lieu, mais ça
s'est passé. Les insurgés du 14 juillet
qui ont changé le monde finalement,
enfin
oui, le monde suivant a été radicalement
changé. par la Révolution française en
portant des programmés incroyables. Les
droits de l'homme, la souveraineté
populaire, la division des pouvoir et
cetera. Le
les les insurgés du 14 juillet bah ont
été nourris
par Rousseau, par Diterro, par Eléticus,
euh par Voltaire, enfin par les par les
grands euh par les grands penseurs
écrivains de la deuxème moitié. du 18e
siècle et ce savoir s'est accumulé,
c'est cristallisé en utopie
et un jour l'incarnation il lieu et donc
c'est notre travail le tien et le mien
sans vouloir nous gonfler
particulièrement bien que tous les
écrivains sont valiteux forcément donc
moi je fais pas l'exception le
notre rôle sart a dit connaître
l'ennemi, combattre l'ennemi Est-ce
qu'on est l'ennemi ? C'est nous. C'est
euh
Jean, je te coupe.
Laisse-moi juste dire une anecdote. Sart
a rencontré Fan Fano, l'auteur des dames
de la terre, psychiatre noir,
des anti qui a pris les armes avec le
FLN et qui est mort malheureusement euh
avant la libération de l'Algérie. La
première fois, la seule fois d'ailleurs,
excuse-moi, euh à l'ôé nationale à Rome
en août 61. En août 61,
première rencontre, seule rencontre
entre Sartre et Fanon et le lendemain,
Sartre écrit à Simon de Boire qui est
resté à Paris,
nous sommes les semeurs devant, la
tempête c'est lui. Nous sommes les
semeurs devant, le tempête c'est lui.
Connaître l'ennemi, combattre l'ennemi.
Connaître l'ennemi, c'est c'est les
intellects, les écrivains, les
journalistes, les
c'est les ennemis eux.
Non, l'ennemi c'est l'oligarchie, c'est
l'ordre carnival du monde et mais nous
on doit et c'est ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui, je pense. Pourquoi tu as
créé cette émission formidable ? C'est
pour combattre l'ennemi, pour arracher
le masque, pour détruire la l'oppression
néolibérale, pour libérer la conscience
collective. Emmanuel Kant a dit
"L'inhumanité
infligée un autre détruit l'humanité en
moi". Pour mettre à jour cette évidence.
Mais c'est l'insurrection populaire qui
va combattre l'ennemi. Tout c'est
connaître l'ennemi, donner les concepts
analytiques
et les peuples donc fan les insurgés et
cetera et maintenant la société civile
les centaines de milliers de jeunes et
adolescents qui tous les vendredis vont
dans les rues d'Europe occidentale aussi
en France pour réclamer que les États
mettent à genou arrêtent le bras
meurtrier des oligarques
du capitalisme financier pour sauver ce
qui reste de nature et de planète de
chance de vie sur cette planète. Je te
reprend une
gilet ja aussi une espérance incroyable
incroyable.
Jean Jean avant de parler des gilets
jaunes, est-ce que tu penses qu'il y a
une faille des intellectuels ? Est-ce
que tu penses que maintenant on n plus
qu'une population d'experts qui font les
tours des plateaux télé qui brassent un
peu de vent ? beaucoup de fumée et et
non, j'ai enfin écoutez
moi je suis un intellectuel c'est un
producteur d'idée
il y a rien d'autre à Dorna euh
l'intelligenceur de vent c'est toi qui
les qui les appelle comme ça
c'est qui dit les semeur de vent nous
sommes les semeurs de vent
la tempête c'est lui c'est le peuple
insurgé et qui ensuite change le mond
C'est un processus très mystérieux.
À quelle condition cette incarnation de
Satan, à quelle condition les idées que
nous produisons qui sont reçues par la
conscience collective
mais pas
transformé en action parce que une
conscience collective qui est muselée
encore qui n'a qui s'est pas libéré de
l'obsolantisme néolibéral.
L'intellectuel
d'abord est un incroyable privilégié.
Toi, moi nous trois, nous quatre ici
incroyable privilégié. Nous sommes
blancs. 13 % de la population du monde
est blanche et n'a jamais été plus. 13 %
lui est pas blanc mais c'est pas grave.
Oui. Sont des blancs et qui règnent sur
cette planète depuis 500 ans avec des
systèmes d'oppression toujours nouveaux.
Je prends mon exemple. Je m'excuse pas
par vanité, mais moi toute ma vie, j'ai
été payé pour penser. Toute ma vie, j'ai
jamais levé une, j'ai jamais levé une
machette. J'ai jamais produit rien du
tout. La seule chose que ce que je
porte, c'est d'autres qui ont produit.
Les soulets, sont d'autres qui ont qui
qui qui ont gardé les vaches et puis le
cuir est arrivé, un cordon est arrivé.
Ce que je mange, c'est d'autres qui qui
plantent.
Moi intellectuel, je ne sais produire
que des biens symboliques. Que des biens
symboliques. Et j'ai été payé toute ma
vie par les sommet du vent
par les contribuables jeunois, par les
ouvriers, les employés, les bourgeois,
les petits bourgeois, le prolétariat
jeune noir de la République de Genève
qui a payé mon salaire.
P qui se paye d'ailleurs une excellente
université.
Qui est une excellente université mais
moi je suis un privilégié incroyable.
Revenons à nos gilets jaunes. Jean euh
les gilets jaunes, est-ce que c'est
Mais tu tu comprends ? Moi, j'étais
rapporteur spécial pour le droit à
l'alimentation. J'ai vu des choses
pendant 8 ans sur la Sierra des Chocotan
au Guatemala
en Mongolie dans les dans les smoky
mountain de de Manille, enfin les
montagnes d'ordure où les gens essayent
de suivre dans les favellas de euh
du Malaganian.
Tu as été au Malais
?
Malaoui ? Bien sûr, lors de la grande
famille, j'étais en 2002, effrayant.
Enfin bref, j'ai vu mourir. Enfin, on
oublie évidemment bah parce que ce qui
est extraordinaire avec la femme, moi
j'avais pensé d'origine bourgeoise
d'origine bourgeoise Boupé, elle était
président du tribunal colonel dans
l'armée de miles la confédération. Je
suis né dans une petite ville médiévale
au pied des des Alpes Pernoises
calvinistes, vous imaginez ? le
ministre. Donc bon, moi comme tout le
monde de ce milieu peut-être même toi,
je croyais que mourir la fin c'était une
c'est une chose assez paisible. C'était
comme une bougie
qui qui s'éteint lentement
parce que la fin c'est une chose tout à
fait simple si on ose dire.
Chaque fois que je parle, que je marche,
même quand je que je marche même quand
je rêve et cetera, je dépense de
l'énergie vitale et cette énergie vitale
doit être
reconstituée
reconstitué par l'apport de nourriture
liquide ou ou stable ou
des calories.
Et on appelle ça des calories. On mesure
ça en calorier pour un homme euh dans
nos régions avec un travail normal, il
faut 2200 calories individu adulte par
jour et des millions et des millions
l'ont pas. Bref, or
l'agonie par la fin c'est est une des
choses les plus horribles, une des
agonies les plus terribles qui qui vit
sur cette planète. avant euh
d'abord le sous-alimenté, l'enfant
sous-alimenté euh qui reçoit pas assez
de calories euh
utilise ses réserves, son corps utilise
les réserves de graisse et de sucre et
cetera et ce musc
ensuite les infections du métabolisme
qui commencent qui sont déjà très
douloureux. Ensuite, c'est la structure
musculaire
qui se qui se défait. Les enfants du sud
soudain qu'on peut voir à la télévision,
parfois il nous gardent bien de nous les
montrer vraiment pendant quelques
secondes. C'est comme des petits animaux
couchés dans la poussière parce qu'ils
peuvent plus se tenir sur sur les
jambes. Ensuite, c'est finalement la
structure immunitaire
qui s'effondre et ensuite vient la mort.
Et c'est une c'est une des morts les
plus effroyables
qu'on peut observer ou qu'on peut vivre
euh sur cette planète
parce que c'est une mort lente et
douloureuse,
lente et frein douloureuse et totalement
sur ces planètes encore une fois
justifié uniquement par l'action
l'action de l'homme, le profit, les
multinationales et cetera. Alors
j'ai une question internet avant que tu
recommences. Le capitalisme et
l'oligarchie
qui le dirige ne sont-ils pas devenus
suffisamment puissants pour contrecarrer
toute révolution visant à un changement
de système économique ?
Bah c'est des bonnes questions là.
Non, je dis d'abord il n'y a pas, c'est
ce qui est à mon avis qui est
fondamental, il n'y a pas de
d'impuissance en démocratie. La France a
beaucoup beaucoup de
de défauts si vous voulez. Enfin,
lesquel ?
Bah par exemple l'utilisation des armes
LGB de
Ouais.
que que
de balle de défense, lanceur de balle de
défense LBD4 lanceur de balle de défense
euh à 3 m que les que les gendarmes et
les policiers et les ARS utilisent à 3 m
de
Ils sont pas à 3 m, ils sont à 15 m.
Mais c'est
Non non non non non. Il y en a 3 m hein.
Il y a plusieurs centaines Il y a
plusieurs centaines de manifestants
pacifique parce que les gilets jaunes il
exercent un droit constitutionnel.
L'ONU ils ont dit un truc par rapport au
respect des droits de l'homme en France.
Bien sûrement ils ont nous notre conseil
des droits de l'homme a condamné
l'utilisation des armes et ce qui est
horrible ils sont fabriqués en Suisse
d'ailleurs à Tun dans ma ville d'origine
ils sont exportés librement.
C'est un seul, c'est bruquer et c'est un
une seule usine qui fait ça exporté en
France et utilisé euh par la police, par
les forces de l'ordre et causant des
centaines. Il y a des centaines
de mutilés. Te mutiler, ça veut dire tes
yeux arrachés, tes mains arrachées.
Ça c'est pour les grenades ça.
Bah les grenades et les les les balles
de
alors complètement condamné mais le
conseil d'état incroyable
incompréhensiblement en France accepté.
Le gouverneur français continue à
accepter. C'est je donne un exemple, je
je vraiment un exemple. J'ai été il y a
15 jours au Glière au Glière euh en
Haute Savoie où il y avait un territoire
libéré. La résistance avait libéré un
territoire qui était écrassé ensuite par
l'occupant allemand et par la milice. Et
les
militants enfin ceux qui adhèrent au
programme de la résistance se réunissent
pendant 3 jours tous les mois de mai au
Gliè plutôt au village en bas. au
village en bas et puis le dimanche
matin, on monte vers le monument d'égli
vers le plateau propanti et je signais
mon livre tranquillement
et tout à coup il y a devant moi un
jeune homme mais vraiment horrible ça
pourrait être mon euh mon petitfils
enfin vous comprenez on fait tout de
suite le liste qui avait un bandeau sur
le sur de l'œil mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe là et bien c'est à Grenoble qu'on
m'a crevé l'œil qui a une un gendarme un
policier et cetera et cetera qui a tiré
à portant très près dans l'œil de ce
très jeune homme qui est mutilé à vie à
et ça continue cette horreur alors que
les gilets jaunes peuvent j'ai j'ai vu
d'ailleurs les gilets jaunes m'ont
contacté et cetera et cetera et j'ai vu
un document qui m'a glacé le sang qui
vient du ministère de l'intérieur qui se
sont procurés que vous connaissez
peut-être parce qu'ils l'ont diffusé où
le ministère de l'intérieur le ministre
de l'intérieur
le le Cartessoau donne ordre au
procureur parce que c'est normal au
parquet qui dit deux choses.
Si quelqu'un est poursuivi parce qu'il a
écrasé un gilet jaune sur un rond-point
et bien il faut le traiter avec
indulgence. Faut le traiter avec
indulgence. réclamer une peine. Très
très
crois que c'était par rapport à un
routier rouain qui avait pété un câ. Non
mais enfin c'est c'est c'est un décret
un une circulaire qui a qui a qui a
force de décret et si et si les gilets
jaunes contre eux il faut appliquer la
loi dans toute sa rigueur
si je te si dans la République française
qui est un modèle dans le monde où les
droits de l'homme sont nés
alors je reviens à
attends attends c'est moi qui te pose
une autre question si je te dis
j'ai pas terminé C'est pas il n'y a pas
d'impuissance en démocratie. Il y a pas
d'impuissance en démocratie. Tu me
disais tout à l'heure enfin tu la
question la question du camarade
peut-être c'est même pas un camarade
enfit qui peut-être
une une camarade ou même
une dame distinguée du 16e qui dit mais
enfin
on peut rien faire.
Misérabilisme de l'impuissance. Miss
Bah si nous étions au endur maintenant
ce soir ou au Pékin peut-être, mais en
France nous sommes à Paris, il n'y a pas
d'impuissance en démocratie. La France a
des défauts, il y a de la corruption. Il
y a justement cette répression
effroyable, mutilante de la police face
à des gilets jaunes qui ne font que
utiliser, concrétiser des droits
constitutionnels
qui le sont assurés en tant que citoyen
et citoyennes. Malgré tout ça, la France
est une vraie vivante démocratie. Une
vraie vivante démocratie. Et il n'y a
pas nous avons tous les droits,
toutes les armes en main juridique,
pacifique, démocratique pour abattre c.
Tu as mangé du lion avant de venir hein.
Non, tu vois.
Bon, alors je te pose une question.
Est-ce que tu es convaincu de ça ? Qu'il
y a pas d'impuissance en démocratie ?
Si je te dis la chef de l'IGPN, tu sais
ce que c'est l'IGPN ou
inspection générale de la police
nationale ? Sa déclaration c'est elle
réfute totalement les termes de violence
policière sur les gilets jaunes.
Bah elle est payé pour ça. Ça c'est
c'est c'est totalement inintéressant.
C'est normal.
Bah elle dirige la répression qui
mutile, qui arrache tes yeux qui
elle dirige des enquêtes sur les flics
qui font.
Mais oui mais elle fait partie de la
grande maison. Mais il était évident que
qu'elle nie la réalité. Enfin qu'elle
nie la réalité. Bien des collectifs de
médecins. Enfin, pour je pourrais te
donner des témoignages multiples et ce
jeune homme qui m'a tellement frappé
quand j'ai parlé au gllière euh du
capitalisme de mon livre, ils m'ont
invité pour euh mon livre
le capitalisme expliqua ma petite fille
en espérant qu'il envois
invité et et j'ai vu ce mutil mutiler à
bout portant volontairement. Tu fais
référence à un gend par un policier
français.
Tu fais référence Tu fais référence aux
médecins qui sont regroupés pour
dénoncer l'usage du LBD
concernant les traumas que ça pouvait
faire sur
totalement.
Les Suisses ils perçoivent un peu ça.
Ils sont ils sont conscients queils
exportent des armes en France qui sont
utilisées pour faire de la répah. La
Suisse est totalement dominée par
l'oligrachie bancaire. La Suisse est
c'est un pays passionnant. Il y a quatre
cultures, des vraies cultures qui se
comprennent d'ailleurs pas entre elles.
Euh moi, j'ai été pendant longtemps
longtemps député de Genève au Parlement
de la confédération, ça servit à rien du
tout. Mais la démocratie suisse qui a
750 200 maintenant historiquement si si
on le prend euh c'est une confédération
de 26 États qui ont des droits de
souveraineté très très fort l'école, la
justice, la police et cetera et cetera
fiscal. Cette confération est tout à
fait passionnant comme comme
formation sociale, comme figure
historique, mais est totalement dominé
par cette olarchie bancair calviniste
qui sont d'une grande habilité, d'un
cynisme total et qui ont une seule
matière première, c'est l'argent
d'autrui et l'argent étranger. La Suisse
n'a aucune matière première. Un peu
d'eau qui tombe des montagnes et qui
tombe de l'électricité mais à part ça
aucune matière première et c'est le
deuxè pays le plus riche de la terre
revenu par tête habitant sur la liste de
la banque mondiale tout de suite elle
est rec comment ils font et bien c'est
l'argent de du crime organisé du monde
entier qui est lavé en Suisse. C'est
l'argent des dictateurs. J'appelle ça
l'argent du sang. les fortunes de Mobutu
de Kabila et cetera et cetera de de
Marcos tous les truants du monde qui ont
des fortunes colossal de plusieurs
milliards pour pour Mobutou puisque il y
a des chiffres là mondial plus de 4
milliards de dollars à la ban
de surx
cette décapitalisation des pays les plus
pauvres avec par ces releurs mondiaux
qui sont les banquiers
fait que les enfants meurent de faim au
Congo. Maintenant, j'étais récemment à
Goma dans le Nord Kivou.
Ils sont pas tous releurs quand même.
Non, non, mais les enfants meurent de
faim à cause de la décapitalisation
organisée avec la complicité des banques
suisses des dirigeants congolais à
Kinshasa à 3000 km vers l'ouest du du
Congo. Donc, c'est bien l'argent du
sang. l'argent du sang, il ne coule pas
sur les façades à des banques à Siric, à
Lugano et et à Genève, mais mais c'est
mais mais c'est l'argent du sang, c'est
tout comme et ensuite bien sûr l'argent
euh de la fuite fiscale. La France a été
pillée pillée pillée pillée par les
comptes élevétiques bien avant Kaosac
qui était un exemple assez formidable.
Euh
autre grande démocratie, l'Allemagne a
été pillée pillée pillée pillée par les
construction pour abriter la fite des
capitaux pour échapper au fisque. Et
bien c'est trois sources
argent criminel, argent du sang du
Tiermonde et argent
évasion fiscale
et de l'évasion fiscale qui font c'est
incroyable incroyable
Je te repose une une question sur les
Nations unies
puiss puissance de l'arie mais on saute
un pied excuse j'ai j'ai répondu à ces
questions parce que c'est des pan de
question
bah heureusement mais t'inquiète il y en
a une liste longue comme le bras ne
t'inquiète pas
euh je t'en pose une autre est-ce que
les Nations- Unies prennent position
contre la France qui vend des armes à
l'Arabie Saoudite qui va cartonner
ensuite le Yémen.
Non, formellement non.
Ça sert encore à quelque chose des
Nations Unies. Oh, attends attends, il
faut être
l'actuel secrétaire général
là, excusez-moi, je vais prendre un
coup, je vais prendre un coup
l'actuel secrétaire général Antonio
Gérès que je connais bien parce qu'il
était il était euh président de
l'international, enfin, il était premier
ministre du Portugal, président du de
l'international socialiste. On a voyagé
ensemble puisque c'était un comité
consultatif, un comité exécutif de
l'international socialiste. Un
catholique de gauche, nombreuses
familles, un vrai portugais d'une
énergie rablée, formidable, alerte,
courageux, d'un type très bien Antony
Rérèz, il est secrétaire général.
Maintenant, la France, elle est une des
cinq puissances permanentes du conseil
de sécurité. Le pouvoir est au conseil
de sécurité qui a 15 membres et cinq
sont les vainqueurs de la 2e guerre
mondial. De Gaul par son intelligence
incroyable a réussi à obtenir un siège
permanent pour la France à travers le
bidonu et cetera. C'était magnifique.
C'est un diplomatie.
un secrétaire général ne peut pas enfin
ou très très difficilement s'il veut
survivre
s'attaquer à un membre permanent de la
du conseil de sécurité. C'est très très
difficile
ce que la France fait surtout que ce que
Hollande a fait parce que c'est lui qui
est responsable des premiers très grands
contrats qui très grand contrat qui
continue maintenant
des de fournitures d'armes ultra
sophistiqué ultra meurtrielle donc à
l'autocratie
obscurantiste terroriste saoudienne
la les livraisons d'armes, c'est un
crime. un crime contre l'humanité parce
que ce qui se passe au Yémen maintenant,
les bombardements de Sana, les les les
massacre de Hova de de du seul port
encore où entre un peu de sac de
nourriture et cetera et cetera,
c'est la terreur d'État pratiquée par
l'Arabie Saoudite et les Émirats avec
des armes
avec tes armes fournies par les
Européens et essentiellement
la France, c'est totalement
inadmissible. Merkel a suspendu la
livraison d'armes allemandes par exemple
et s'est fait attaquer par Macron parce
que les systèmes d'armement les plus
sophistiqués
sont d'une production commune entre
l'Allemagne et la France notamment ou
les Anglais aussi et cetera. Et merkel a
tenu bon, ça il faut le dire et a
suspendu depuis 6 mois maintenant la
livraison d'armes aux Émirats européens
au livraison d'armes armes européennes
donc commune production ou production
allemande tous tout seul toutes les
armes plus d'exportation vers les
Émirats ou vers Riyad vers l'Arabie
Saoudite. La France continue, enfin la
France, c'est pas c'est pas ma France
ça, c'est c'est justement l'antifrance.
Les dirigeants actuels français
continuent à mentir et disent l'aviation
saoudienne n'utilise pas les fusées euh
et les roquettes et cetera français.
Les canons César
ni les blindés, ni ni l'artillerie et
cetera qu'on leur fournit, ni les
munitions qu'on leur fournit.
Alors que c'est une contre vérité totale
constatée. Moi je suis à la commission
d'enquête du on peut pas entrer mais on
peut voir on rencontre des survivants à
Thibouti à Kartou et au Ker. Bah c'est
documenté que les France que que les
salles françaises sont utilisées.
Pourquoi l'Arabie Saoudite achèterait
pour 18 milliards
d'euros d'armes
des des Européens ? 18 milliards
d'euros d'armes des Européens si c'était
pas pour massacrer la population outil
qui est rebelle.
C'est pour se défendre qu'il disent.
Non non non, c'est un c'est un mensonge
total et je ne comprends pas.
La France est un pays tellement
totalement civilisé. Venant de Genève,
je peux je peux le dire. Enfin,
totalement comment c'est comme ces armes
à courte portée qui mut qui mutilent les
les
gilets jaunes
gilets jaunes arrache les yeux arrachent
les mains qui veulent protéger les yeux.
C'est inadmissible, totalement
incompréhensible et je ne comprends
absolument totalement pas comment la
France
qui n'est pas le passoute ou la Russie
et cetera, mais qui est la France peut
mentir à ce point et continuer continuer
à livrer des armes meurtrières à un
régime détestable qui massacre un peuple
étranger,
qui lapide des gens, qui les crucifie,
qui
totalement qui discrimine les femmes,
qui coupe la tête et les mains.
la Charia, tout ça, c'est effrayant euh
incompréhensible, sauf par le
raisonnement capitaliste, la
maximalisation du profit.
Tu as un avis sur le gouvernement Macron
? Emmanuel Macron, c'est un bon
président, c'est pas un bon président.
Moi qui
faire encore des copains là.
Bon non, là il faut faire attention.
Moi, je suis vice-président du comité
consultatif du conseil des droits de
l'homme. La France est un membre
aux Nations- Unies,
hein.
Aux Nations- Unies.
des Nations Unies bien sûr, c'est c'est
mon travail actuel.
C'était mon travail jusqu'à hier. Si
jusqu'à aujourd'hui à midi quoi,
j'aimerais
j'aimerais j'aimerais je retourne à
Genève demain matin. J'aimerais rester
avoir ce poste là parce qu'il permet de
se battre. Il permet de se battre.
Tu penses que tu penses qu'on peut se
battre de l'intérieur ? Ah oui ! Ah bah
écoute, moi je je je vous donner tout à
l'heure là une réponse très précise
là-dessus qui est une question
importante. Euh
mais là on
quelle était la question qui était posée
?
Macron.
Ah Macron, j'ai essayé de le l'éviter.
Non,
je la France est un
pays admirable, puissant, membre du
conseil des droits de l'homme.
Donc ton patron ?
Ouais. Donc je vais être très prudent.
Tu as peur de Tu as peur ?
Bah j'ai peur de rien. Pourquoi ? Enfin
j'ai peur bien sûr de 1000 choses mais
pas que ma femme m'engueule que c maisf
non j'ai pas peur.
Il y a il y a une liberté totale au
conseil des droits de l'homme et la
position que j'ai j'ai l'immunité
l'immunité des Nations unies. chez ce ce
livre
un passeport diplomatique.
Oui, bien sûr. J'aurais ce livre-là,
j'aurais jamais pu l'écrire sans
l'immunité des Nations- Unies. C'est
évident. Quand j'ai écrit la Suisse, la
Suisse lave plus blanc en 81 qui attaqué
le banditisme banquétique. J'étais
membre du parlement. Là, ils m'ont levé
l'immunité parlementaire et l'avalanche
des français venus qui m'a totalement
complètement ruiné parce que une
français, je les ai tous perdus contre
les grandes banques, les avocates
d'affaires et cetera. Aujourd'hui, je
les gagnerai.
Aujourd'hui, ils peuvent pas m'attaquer.
Ils peuvent m'attaquer mais devant la
cour
de justice à la ha et là les procédures
durent.
Donc j'en j'en profite, j'en profite
pour quel j'en profite pour caler une
question de Thomas. En 1990, Jean Zigler
a écrit un livre qui s'intitulaé La
Suisse lave plus blanc où il dressait un
état des lieux du rôle de la Suisse sur
le blanchiment d'argent sale. Quel est
son constat aujourd'hui ?
Rien n'a changé. Le banditisme
banquelque
reparti pour neuf procès.
Non non non attention ça changé d'une
façon
ils ont essayé de te tuer
financièrement. Non avant bah ils ont
réussi j'ai 6,6 millions de Francwiich
du pays. Enfin, je continuer mes comptes
sont bloqués mais je vais pas en parler
parce que je suis encore privilégié
parce que les salles d'audiences des
tribunaux, c'est encore un lieu de
combat et si j'étais une femme de ménage
portugaise depuis depuis longtemps, je
serai loin. Et là, j'ai été réélu au
Parlement, j'ai été nommé aux Nations-
Unies et grâce à ces nominations, je
peux continuer parce que une immunité
plus forte maintenant à à lutter. Donc
je suis encore une fois un privilégié
bien que financièrement ruiné en
souslocation j'ai ma femme mais ça va
bien, je me tiens bien, je fais
attention de et bref là il faut pas
parler de ça mais euh
il a ce mythe le secret bancaire a
disparu.
C'est vrai qu'il y a eu des progrès à
cause de l'OECD, à cause de la société
civile aussi des ONG.
Euh il y a maintenant maintenant depuis
une année l'échange automatique des
informations. C'est dire si un français,
je prends un exemple, si un français
ouvre un compte à Genève à la Coraterie
dans une une des banques euh chez Pité
et cetera, et bien
l'autorité fiscale suisse doit
automatiquement avertir le fisque
français. Ça peut être un compte tout à
fait légal qui est déclaré en France,
c'est pas ça. Donc il y a un échange
automatique d'information
et on dit le secret bancaire c'est
terminé l'évasion fiscale plus possible.
Mais si vous avez
suffisamment de millions pour pour le
dentiste de Lyon ou le notaire de
Bordeaux, ça complique la vie. C'est
vrai. Mais si vous êtes très riche, il y
a des gens très très riches en France.
Bah vous faites une offshore, vous
faites une pyramide société offshore
totalement intransparent, totalement
intransparent. Kellock, l'ancien
directeur de
d'Interpol à Lyon euh a toujours dit "Si
une somme d'argent change trois fois
d'identité, soit monétaire, soit
juridique, son origine est intraçable.
On trouve plus jamais son origine.
Autrement dit, l'échange automatique
information, comment ça va se passer
avec les chol ? Et bien,
il aura une société de Kurassa ou des
Bahamas ou de euh ou des barbou
mettons de courassa qui ouvre un compte
au crédit suisse à Genève ou à l'USBS.
Le fils le fils
envoie un message à Kurasao qui sent la
société Aurore ou la société
donc truc Much peu importe des noms très
très compliqués a ouvert un compte tel
numéro tel endroit tel filiale bancaire
nous vous en informons.
Rien ne se passe. Rien ne se passe parce
personne ne sait qui est le vrai
propriétaire de cette pyramide de
société offshore totalement transparente
qui ont été créé par des avocats au
Panama. Heureusement qu'il y a des
journalistes Panama. Sauf que des Oui,
il y a des journalistes parfois il y a
des fites. Il y a des fites et des
journalistes
et des lanceurs d'alerte
et des lanceurs d'alte boulot
formidable, extraordinaire et ça donne
des millions d'email qui sont transmis à
ce collectif de journalistes de
recherche
oui qui s'appelle ça donne les Panama
PayPal, ça donne les Luxaks, Luxembourg
euh voilà mais ça c'est des moments mais
pour
être tout à fait clair
l'évasion fiscale le le
Rousseau Jean-Jacques Rousseau, ouvrier
horlogéois
que Genève a expulsé dès ses 20 ans.
Il a quitté Genève, ils n'ont même plus
voulu son cadavre quand quand il est
mort à il est au panton.
Ben Rousso a dit "Le riche porte la loi
dans sa bourse. Le riche porte la loi
sans sa bourse.
Et les très riches du monde, ils payent
les impôts qu'ils veulent. et aucun
quelconque
agent du fisque enquêteur, il y en a des
formidables, il font un travail
magnifique n'arrive
à appliquer la loi, à retrouver ces
sommes astronomiques. Le riche, le très
riche décide s'il veut payer des impôts
et si
oui, combien
on fait quoi sur on fait quoi sur
le banditisme pas dehique
pleine florison.
D'accord. Question question d'Internet.
Pourriez-vous préciser l'état des liens
entre la communauté consultative du la
communauté communauté pardon entre le
comité consultatif et le conseil des
droits de l'homme ?
Bah oui, j'ai une question purement
technique mais je veux bien y répondre.
Donc si c'est purement technique, on va
pas
Non non non, je vais je vais répondre.
C'est bien les
alors autre question. Réfléchis à
celle-là parce que j'en profite
maintenant que je pas à prendre un peu
la parole.
Ouais, je vais répondre. Oui. Oui.
Attends tout de suite. Pouvez-vous nous
parler des accusations d'entraav au
programme de lutte contre la fin de
l'ONU ?
Ça, je comprends pas. La première
question, je je vais je vais répondre.
Le Conseil des droits de l'homme, c'est
la troisème instance la plus importante
des Nations Unies. Il y a d'abord le
Parlement des Nassus et de l'assemblée
générale.
193 États du monde, tous les États du
monde, sauf le Vatican, mais là on a
vraiment pas besoin, sont membres des
Nations Unies, l'assemblée générale et
c'est une assemblée générale totalement
démocratique. la Chine 1,4 milliards
d'êtres humains vanatou le plus petit
état des Nations unies membres des
Nations unies 55000 et 55000 habitants
la Chine
le tatou chacun a une loi donc c'est une
assemblée générale totalement
démocratique. Ensuite, il y a le
gouvernement des Nations- Unies. C'est
les 15 États membres du conseil de
sécurité, 10 sont tournants et 5 sont
permanents. Ceux qui en juin 45 ont été
les vainqueurs de la deuxème guerre
mondiale et qui ont été ont reçu la
France, la Chine, l'Angleterre,
le
la Russie,
la Russie
et les États-Unis. Bon,
c'est le gouvernement et le conseil
d'état de l'homme, c'est 47 états élus
au prata des continents comme toujours
les états aux Nations Unies par
l'assemblée générale tous les 3 ans et
ce conseil des droits de l'homme doit
examiner, contrôler d'une façon
permanente dans quelle mesure les 193
États membres des Nations- Unies
respectent la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme. les 31 articles
du du 10 décembre 48 et les conventions
internationales des droits de l'homme
qui se sont créé depuis lors alors ce
conseil des droits de l'homme est
composé d'état donc de d'ambassadeurs et
d'ambassadrices tout à fait concrètement
Genève est un poste qui est très très
recherché par les diplomats du monde
entier donc c'est des en général des
grosses pointures hommes et femmes qui
viennent de Pékin de Bruxelles de
Washington et cetera et cetera, mais qui
sont pas nécessairement des experts des
droits de l'homme. Pourquoi le serait-il
?
Pourquoi il viennent là ? Parce que
c'est une bonne planque parce que ça
paye
non, ils ont été nommés au tournus et
cetera et cetera.
C'est c'est un c'est par exemple
c'est un retour d'ascenseur.
Non, pas du tout. par exemple la
dernière est partie avit une
ambassadrice
euh française euh l'avant-dernier
chef de poste. Bah c'était une une
érudite, une très très grande érudite
des langues orientales. Des langues
orientales. Pour toutes ces raisons,
les les chefs de mission qui siègent au
conseil des droits de l'homme de 47 sont
pas nécessairement des spécialistes des
droits de l'homme. Et donc l'ONU a créé
un comité consultatif de 18 experts,
donc trois occidentaux. Donc moi, j'ai
été élu par l'erreur parce qu'il pensait
professeur suisse tout ça neutre. Ils se
sont un peu trompés mais maintenant
c'est trop tard. qui sont présentés par
leur état et qui sont le comité
consultatif qui préparent les dossiers,
qui font les recommandation, qui n'ont
pas de pouvoir exécutif d'uccune sorte
et ces recommandations, ces dossiers
vont au conseil des droits de l'homme
qui prend des résolutions, qui prend des
décisions. Voilà, on peut parler
question purement technique, mais c'est
bien de savoir comment fonctionne les
contre la torture, contre la
disparition, contre la violation des
droits de l'enfant, de la femme et
cetera, on peut porter plainte à des
mécanismes spécifiques. Vous
az porté plainte pour Julien Assange.
Pour
Julian Assange,
c'est en cours, on est en cours. La
liberté d'expression, c'est le
et ça c'est en cours. C'estàd c'est en
cours
je pense ça va aboutir à quelque chose.
Et ça va aboutir dans combien de temps ?
Bah c'est le rapport de force. C'est le
rapport de force. Heureusement, enfin
heureusement, je te voulais pas dire ça,
les États-Unis
se sont retirés du Conseil des droits de
l'homme. Il n'accep pas la normativité
internationale des droits de l'homme. On
rétablit la torture. Bush exécutif for
Bush a retiré la signature
euh américaine. Bush fils, retirer la
signature américaine sous la convention
internationale interdissant la torture.
C'est
c'est horrible.
C'est totalement horrible. Et pourtant
le conseil des droits de l'homme avec
touses les contradictions qu'il a fait
un travail essentiel, magnifique. Voilà.
Et le comité surtout, excusez-moi,
Eddouard Snowdon, Julien Assange, tous
ces lanceurs d'alerte, Bradley Manning,
Chelsea Manning
font un travail essentiel. Essentiel,
c'est des héros à mon avis créer la
trans
Pourqu ils sont pas protégés en France ?
Comment ?
Pourquoi on les protège pas en France à
ton avis ? Bah, c'est un problème du
rapport de force.
C'est que il y aurait des pays
extérieurs ou nesre qui seraient prêts à
faire des opérations sur notre
territoire. Mon ami est vraiment
Confiana a toujours dit "Les droits de
l'homme progressent à la vitesse des
glaciers."
Ah ouais.
Des glaciers.
Ça tombe bien, c'est le réchauffement
climatique donc ça recule beaucoup en ce
moment. Non mais elle il progresse
et la protection des lance d'alerte est
une des tâches essentielles
du droit international public et donc du
conseil des droits de langue.
Alors moi j'ai une question. Comment on
fait ? Je te je te laisse boire un peu
d'eau. Comment on fait pour produire une
raison analytique radicale en ce moment
? Comment on fait pour produire une
raison analytique radicalement critique
? Enfin, c'est des questions qui vont
C'est une phrase que j'ai extrait de
d'une de tes conférences.
C'est vrai.
Bah nous, il faut, je disais tout à
l'heure, il n'a pas d'impuissance en
démocratie. La France est une grande
puissante
véritable
un conseil pour les gilets jaunes.
Démocratie. Non, faut continuer les
gilets jaunes. Ils ont obtenu un
formidable résultat. forcer le pouvoir
exécutif à à dialoguer non en dehors des
mécanismes de la démocratie
représentative qui est au bout. Il y a
plus de démocratie représentative
euh que les gens acceptent aujourd'hui.
Euh Rousseau 1762 dans ce livre le
contrat social a dressé le modèle de la
de la démocratie
représentative. Je donne ma voix, c'est
une chose assez curieuse, je donne ma
voix pendant 4 ans pour 4 ans à un autre
qui parle en mon nom et je reçois en
retour la protection de la loi. Donc la
la c'est une chose magnifique, c'est une
conquête de la civilisation, la
représentation la représentation la
démocratie représentative
qui a fonctionné jusqu'à maintenant et
tout à coup les gilets jaunes et bien
d'autres personnes
refusent de se faire représenter. Le
député, je le reconnais pas. Il me je
participe pas à son élection. Il me il
est en place mais je dois le payer par
mes contributions. Mais je ne lui
reconnais aucune légitimité. Je veux la
démocratie directe qui s'explique par le
RIC, par le référendum initiative
citoyen par exemple. C'est c'est une des
revendications des gilets jaunes et je
pense c'est une époque qui se termine.
Le même sentiment du refus de la
démocratie représentative tel que
Jean-Jacques Rousseau dans le contrat
social de 1762
l'a décrit et tel qu'elle a été
pratiquée dans la plupart des
démocraties constitut constitutionnelles
de la planète est au bout. Est au bout.
J'ai une autre question. Mais alors la
raison analytique, non, je dis une
chose,
on a toutes les informations. Vous savez
ce qui se passe au Soudan du Sud,
l'horreur qui se passe au Yémen,
l'horreur qui se passe dans la
répression des gilets jaunes. D'une
parole, pour la première fois
maintenant, on a toutes les
informations. Personne ne peut dire, je
sais pas pourquoi les gens mort de faim,
les enfants meurent de faim ou comment
ça se passe. On a la le monde est devenu
transparent. Malgré les efforts des
oligarchies. Non, il y a une formidable
un formidable travail d'informateurs
télévisuel, digital
de la presse et
l'information est est là. communication
en plus en plus en plus dans nos pays
France, Suisse, Allemagne et cetera, bah
on a tous les droits constitutionnels
pour pour pour imposer les réformes
fondamentales qu'il faut. par exemple
interdire la spéculation boursière sur
les aliments de base qui augmentent le
prix du blé, du riz et du maïs en
permanence et qui fait que dans les
bidonvilles du monde, dans les calamass
du du du Pérou, dans les smoking de
Milan de de de des Philippines, la mer
peu importe combien d'enfants de la
maison ne peut plus acheter suffisamment
de nourriture parce que les spéculateurs
ont fait augmenter dans les bourses de
France, de Chicago, euh de Zic, de
Londres, le prix
du riz en pochant des
profits incroyables, totalement intent
et bien on peut interdire demain matin
la spéculation
boursière sur les aliments de passe et
d'ailleurs sarcé c'est incroyable ça
vous prouve parce que je reviens modif
pour pour que les pour que ce soit
préci.
Combien il vaut ton livre ? Combien il
coûte ?
Euh 10 €.
Ah bah voilà, ça va. C'est pas trop
cher.
Pas trop cher ? Non. Puis ça va tê son
de toute façon. Combien
combien tu gagnes ?
Je gagne rien parce que tuas comptes
sont bloqués. Là j'ai fait un accord ça
va à Sentinelle. C'est une branche de
terre des hommes. C'est l'aide aux
enfants
du nom. Du nomade la sous-alimentation
crée une des horrible maladie.
sousalimentation sousalimentation
s'appelle le nom qui mange les tissus
mou du visage qui laisse tomber les yeux
qui qui défigure totalement les enfants
qui bloque la bouche. La mer casse les
dents pour pouvoir envoyer un peu de
liquide enfin nourriture liquide pour
l'enfant. Le nom est absolument
totalement horrible et c'est une une
maladie tropicale
non transmissible, pas reconnue par
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé mais
qui tue et qui mutile des dizaines et
des dizaines de milliers d'enfants sur
ton africtoire sur toi et cetera. Et il
y a une société une je fais un peu de
propagande d'organisation
liée à terre des hommes créé par
l'hythmocaire qui s'appelle Sentinelle
et qui essae d'aider ses enfants. Il y a
il y a des des chirurgiens français par
exemple, suisse ou autres qui vont à
Wakadouu, qui vont à Niamé, qui vont à
Contenous opérer, reconstituer ses
visages si on peut parce que c'est
l'absurdité absolue. Si la Melle avait
300 € quand les premiers infections à la
mchoale se produisent, avec 3 €
d'antibiotique, on pourrait arrêter le
nom. Bon, ces populations l'ont pas. Et
donc c'est la chirurgie euh réparatrice
faite gratuitement, magnifiquement par
des chirurgicien français suisse
avec avec la vie. Voilà
avec la vie que tu as eu
avec la vie que tu as toujours pas eu
moi. Je vais pas mourir demain.
Comment tu fais comment tu fais pour
encore dormir avec tout tous ces gens
qui étaient ravagés par la maladie,
ravagé par la faim, ravagé par les
guerres ? tous les camps de rétention
administrative que tu as pu visiter,
toute cette misère, toutes toutes toutes
ces ces horreurs.
Comment tu fais pour encore dormir ?
Est-ce que tu te réveilles la nuit et tu
dis par exemple "Réveillez-vous". Euh
est-ce que est-ce que tu as tu fais des
cauchemars ? Est-ce que tu as le le même
syndrome que les les gens qui ont été
exposés sur des théâtres d'opération ?
Est-ce que
d'abord ça n'intéresse personne la
psychologie du petit bourgeois jeunois ?
Ça n'intéresse pas l'enfant qui me fa ce
qui l'intéresse, c'est l'efficacité.
Est-ce qu'il va avoir de l'aide ou pas ?
Vous comprenez ? Ça sert à rien de de
dire qu'est-ce qu'il sent ce rapporteur
spécial. J'essaie de ne pas y penser. De
toute façon, c'est l'efficacité qui
compte et les est totalement
insuffisante en matière dans dans mon
dans mon dans mon travail. Mais c'est
vrai que psychologiquement
ça vous travaille et surtout quand on
ment aux victimes. Quand je suis, je
l'ai écrit dans mon livre, quand je suis
dans la Sierra de Chocotan au Guatemala
2000 m d'altitude en bas dans la terre
noire le long du Pacifique où Nighted
Fruit euh enfin bref de euh general food
et cetera, des dizaines de kilomètres de
plantation de de
d'anas, de banane de grapfruit et cetera
et cetera et la population qui vivait là
chassée dans la montagne les Indiens
Maya où ils vivent à 2000 m sur un sol
euh pierreux euh essayant de planter de
survivre avec quelques tiges de maïs et
cetera. Des femmes qui a 30 ans ont
l'air de 80 ans qui ont des beaux yeux
noirs mais qui sont les enfants qui ont
des des bras et des jambes comme des
allumettes et cetera. Bref, et j'arrive
avec mes interprètes, avec les gens de
sécurité, avec mes assistants en mission
Côté sur la Sense et des Chocotan pour
introgger ces gens.
Bon, pendant 3 jours, personne ne nous
répond parce qu'on était blanc et
cetera. Et après la 3è journée, je le
décris dans le capitalisme expliqué à ma
petite fille.
Tout à coup, les vieux commencent à
parler.
raconte ce qu'ils vivent parce que les
grands latifondium indigènes et
étrangers s'agrandissent tout le temps.
C'est des pistolos qui se le lafondire
un grand propriétaire du café par
exemple à mi-uteur c'est pas c'est pas
le Pacifique à mi-auteur.
pour pour augmenter sa pour augmenter
son territoire, sa propriété, il envoie
quelques pistoléros dans le village
indien Maya voisin, tu
le reste s'enfuit dans la montagne et il
dép il agrandit euh sa propriété. Bon
bref, les gens finalement après 3 jours
nous parlent et nous racontent ce qu'ils
vivent, l'expropriation,
le sous-paiement comme travailleur comme
travailleur saisonnier et cetera ce ceux
qui vivent le dé total de droit.
Et moi
je leur promets de les aider parce que
c'est qu'il faut évidemment c'est une
réforme agraire d'abord une réform 1,6 %
des 100 millions population globale 10
millions du Guatemala entre les Caraïbes
et et le Pacifique 1,6 % des
propriétaires indigènes et étrangers ont
67 % des terres arables. Donc c'est
évident réforme agraire et je dis
au
aux gens de la communauté aux anciens là
qui qui qui sont les porte-paroles de
toute la foule là dans la nuit, c'est la
nuit parce que le jour s'est fait trop
chaud de se réunir. Je leur dis, je vous
promets que je me battrai pour la
réforme agréaire,
pour le crédit pour le crédit agréaire
pour que les tribunaux militaires ne
jugent plus qui sont seuls compétents
aujourd'hui des conflits agré. Je fais
des promesses et je sais d'avance que je
serai battu à New York. Je le sais.
Et je vois je vois bah
ils veulent des solutions, ils veulent
qu'est-ce que tu fais là ? Qu'est-ce que
c'est ? et et et je vois naître
l'espérance.
Or c'est un exemple tout à fait concret,
c'est la mission du guemala. J'ai j'ai
ensuite 3 mois pour remettre au
secrétaire général mes recommandations
la situation analytique et mes
recommandation et le secrétaire général
le transfère au conseil des droits de
l'homme enfin le
vérifie des choses techniques transfert
le conseil des droits de l'homme qui
décide et dans ce délai qui était à peu
près 6 mois à la prochaine session du
conseil d'urgence dans ce délai
où nighted fruit tel moné et cetera
et les propriétés la fontière mais
surtout les multinationales américaines
se sont mobilisés se sont mobilisés et
ont mobilisé le state department et
l'ambassadeur américain
le département d'état département d'État
et l'ambassadeur américain a créé une
alliance à l'intérieur du conseil des
droits de l'homme majoritaire pour
attaquer toutes mes toutes mes
recommandations.
La réforme agréaire était caractérisée
comme une atteinte à la liberté du
marché, comme une mesure communiste
inadmissible et cetera et cetera.
Il n'y a pas de registre. J'ai demandé
d'abord un registre foncier.
Le Guatemala est devenu indépendante de
l'Espagne, la République Guatemala en
1825. Depuis le 1825 jusqu'aujourd'hui,
il n'a même pas un registre foncier
cadastre. Il y a pas de cadastre. On on
ne sait pas juridiquement quelles sont
les limites des différents
propriétaires.
Même si les propriétaires d'une
dimension
d'une extension tout à fait indécente et
qui grandit grand garantit et bien
on connaît pas un il y a pas de
catastre. Donc pour faire une réforme
agrée, il faut d'abord un castre. J'ai
demandé un catastre.
C'éit quoi ma question ?
Ensuite la réforme agrée.
Non. C'était quoi ma question ?
Comment la question ? Mais qu'est-ce qui
com arriv à dormir ? Ouais. Comment
comment tu encaisses ça ? Tu bosses, tu
vas sur le terrain
comment il se sent ? On s'en fout.
D'accord. Je suis peu de temps sur cette
planète. Je veux que ça change. Pointe à
la ligne. Alors si tu veux aller plus
profondément, moi je crois que ma vie a
un sens,
que l'histoire a un sens. J'aurais ça
dit.
Tu crois au karma ?
Non, je crois à Dieu. Point. Terminé. Tu
as un ami imaginaire, tu lui parles
qui ?
Dieu.
Bah là je Oui, bien sûr. Je prie, je
suis sûr. Ah écoute, d'une chose ça me
semble évident. D'une chose me deux
choses me sembl évident. J'aurais ça dit
la route est bortée de cadavre mais elle
mène à la justice et l'humanisation de
l'homme est en cours. L'histoire a un
sens. Ceux qui sont tombés pour la
justice sont pas tombés en vain ni
devant la pastie, ni aujourd'hui dans la
guerri euh Sara, ni nulle part. Ceux qui
ont donné leur vie ou enfin qui ont
risqué donner leur vie sont pas tombés,
l'ont pas risqué. Enfin, l'histoire a un
sens, ma vie a un sens. Si je croyais
par exemple que je suis le produit là
devant toi d'une nuit de danse de fête
dans l'oberland pernois dans la région
de Toun là dans les centes pernoises où
un ovule et un sperme se sont trouvés
vers l'aube et moi et le petit cycle il
arrive si
c'était le produit du hasard
bah je me pendrais c'est pas possible ma
vie a un sens je le sens enfin je c'est
une évidence là on est au-delà de la
raison analytique, tu comprends ? Mais
mais il y a mais il y a une mais mais il
y a il y a des évidences
subconscient
sub conceptuelle infraconceptuel
infraconceptuel
comme différents sociologues l'ont
toujours affirméti
il y a il y a des évidences
infraconceptuelles. une évidence
infraconceptique, c'est que ma vie a un
sens et quand je meurs, c'est mon corps
qui meurt naturellement puisque la le le
renouvellement cellulaire, c'est tous
les 7 ans, il va se ralentir et
s'arrêter à un moment à un certain
moment il s'arrête, il y a une mort
naturelle mais pour la conscience il n'y
a pas de mort naturelle parce que la
conscience c'est cumulatif, elle est
destinée
à à l'éternier sart. a dit une chose
magnifique enfin très très juste très
intelligent il a dit toute mort est un
assassinat pour la conscience pour la
conscience
la conscience s'arrête parce que
substrat physiologique le système
nerveux les sou les sens ne sont plus là
pour concrétiser cette conscience sur
cette planète mais la conscience
continue à vivre parce que son système
elle n'a pas de mort naturel
toute
La conscience est affectée par
l'interruption
de la mort du substrat
par par une introduction mais continue à
vivre. Alors de quelle façon au-delà
de
l'identité
ma personne c'est pas dans la mémoire
des gens comme ça a dit pour Marx et
cetera. Non ça c'est inintéressant. Moi
en tant que personne, moi en tant que
conscience cumulative, mon magnifique
petitfils
euh passionné de ton émission Théo, bah
il est formidablement intelligent.
Enfin, je suis un peu euh
je manque d'objectivité comme tous les
grands-pères bien sûr, très intelligent
mais il a beaucoup moins de contenu de
conscience que moi parce que je suis
beaucoup plus âgé et rien ne fait que
cette accumulation de contenu de
conscience s'arrête. Il y a pas de mot
naturel pour la conscience. Donc je
crois à la résurrection de quelle façon
ça se fait. Mais c'est moi ma personne
qui est et c'est pas eu un brouillard
quelque part dans la mémoire collective.
Donc voilà, tu me demandes pourquoi ma
motivation, le combat,
bah finalement c'est ça la source.
Tu fais tu fais pénitence ?
Bah rien du tout. Je je réponds comme
Victor Hugo. Je déteste toutes les
églises.
J'aime les hommes. Je croise en Dieu.
Victor Hugo.
Je te j'en profite pour passer une
question. J'ouvre une parenthèse. Le
Vatican peut-être un peut-il être un
allié dans la lutte contre le
capitalisme ?
C'est Ouais. Donc
il faudrait surtout le dissoudre
immédiatement.
Tu imagines le
tous ces Michelange Raphaël toutes ces
immenses ça pour les nourrir des
centaines de milliers d'enfants ? Enfin
je prends que réponse très très simple.
En plus, le Christ, comme disait Renan,
est venu sur terre pas pour conquérir le
pouvoir et la richesse, mais pour les
détruire.
Renant, la vie de Jésus, le Christ est
venu sur terre non pas pour s'emparer de
la puissance et de l'argent et de la
richesse, mais pour les détruire. Bah le
Vatican,
c'est cool. Mais le pape est pas mal
hein, le
nouveau là. Ah, il y a pas mal du tout
hein. Il a tu ces choses le Vatican, il
faut dissoudre. Bon, bien sûr et et
rapidement et complètement bon
distribuer les bien. Le pape, il a écrit
un livre enfin de dialogue avec un
journaliste Victor Chelli. Euh le nom de
la le nom de Dieu et miséricorde, c'est
c'est le titre français où il dit
quelque chose de tout à fait
extraordinaire.
Il a maintenant une nouvelle catégorie
d'hommes sur sur terre qui sont plus ni
les exploités euh ni les dominés
euh et cetera, mais qui sont des déchets
pape jésuite incroyable
qui sont des déchets, c'est-à-dire qui
sont expulsés d'une façon définitive de
toute vie sociale et économique qui
n'auront jamais
de travail, jamais nuit de famille,
jamais une dignité humaine, jamais des
soins, jamais d'école et cetera qui sont
des déchets de l'humanité
et Colin le Xavier
Colin de enfin le
l'économiste d'Oxford
dans son fameux livre euh
ça va t'inquiète pas la la communauté va
nous fournir le nombre en 4 secondes
le dit ils sont 1 milliard
sur de cette territoire que nous sommes,
selon le pape, il y a 1 milliard de
déchets de gens totalement privés de vie
sociale, communautaire, économique et
cetera et cetera et qui n'auront jamais
une place quelconque, même sous forme
d'exploiter, même sous forme de
marginaliser, même sous forme de dominer
dans l'ordre cannibal du monde. C'est
quand même extraordinaire qu'il qu'il
puisse dire ça. C'est pas un membre de
de la ligue marxiste léniniste, c'est le
pape en exercice à Rome.
J'ai une question d'internet.
J'ai bien peur qu'il ne vivent pas très
longtemps.
Pourquoi il va se faire assassiner par
les gardes suisses ?
Euh non, les gardes suisses c'est
totalement inutile. C'est un rica moyen
âgeux assez ridicule. C'est
Non, mais il a sûrement des amis parce
qu'il y a déjà des papes qui ont été
assassinés.
Et celui-là qui prend l'Évangile au
sérieux et bien il pose problème à pas
mal de d'hiérarques éclésiaux
et les réseaux jésuites sont encore bien
organisés et sont toujours bien présents
pour défendre l'intérêt général. J'ai
une question d'internet. Est-ce que vous
n'accusez pas un peu le capitalisme de
tous les mots naturels qui se sont
toujours abattus sur l'humanité ? Mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire sur
l'humanité ? une question de choui.
Mais non, je je vis maintenant, je
regarde le monde tel qu'il est. Il y a
euh
un nom que je déteste plus que tout
autre quand on me traite d'igaliste.
Non, je suis un marxiste, je suis
matérialiste, je suis un sociologue. Je
regarde le monde et je dis cet ordre du
monde est totalement meurtrier. J'ai
donné les chiffres, la fin de l'eau
pollué, noma et cetera.
Mais en plus absurde. Pour la première
fois dans l'histoire, l'humanité serait
capable de nourrir, de vêtir, euh de de
scolariser, de soigner tout le monde. Je
je prends un exemple. Marx est mort le
14 mars 83 1883
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'au dernier souffle
de vie 2h de l'après-midi. Il était
persuadé Carl Marc s'était persuadé. Il
est mort dans son fauteuil, dans son
modest logement plutôt in dit à Londres
paisiblement jusqu'au dernier souffle,
il était persuadé que le manque
objectif, comme il appelait le
objectivement le manque objectif,
c'est-à-dire le déséquilibre entre les
biens
disponibles sur cette planète et les
besoins incompressibles,
ce décalage
insuffisamment de bien pour les besoins
de tout le monde que ce manque objectif
allait durer des générations et des
générations encore et et comme il disait
le le couple maudit du maître et de
l'esclave qui lutte pour les peu de
biens qui sont là la lutte classe par
exemple aller accompagner
l'humanité pendant des des générations
des générations des générations encore
et toute sa théorie
de la lutte classe, de la division
internationale du travail, de la nature
épisoménale
de l'État. Toute la théorie politique de
Marx est basée sur cette hypothèse de la
permanence
de
la du manque objectif. Or, ce manque
objectif depuis 83, grâce à une
formidable succession de révolution
technologique
euh électronique scientifique
que j'ai décrit un peu
déclenché par les oligarchies entre
autres,
j'ai à supprimé le manque objectif.
Aujourd'hui, on aurait suffisamment de
bien. Il y a plus aucune fatalité pour
pour la fin par exemple. suffisamment de
de bien pour nourrir,
former scolariser,
soigner comment qu'il y a des gens qui
faire vivreement je parle uniquement du
bonheur matériel.
Comment tuexpliques qu'il y a des gens
qui crèvent de de sur de surbouffe
d'obésité ?
Moi ça m'intéresse pas.
Bah souvent l'obésité si moi moi je vais
évidemment souvent aux États-Unis où
c'est une effroyable histoire. Enfin, je
on voit tellement de gostes adolescents
gros, malsin, le teint malsin et cetera.
En général,
euh après la 125e rue, enfin dans les
Harlem,
dans les à la Bowerie, tout à fait au
sud de l'île de Manhattan, dans les
quartiers pauvres, dans les quartiers
pauvres parce qu'ils ont pas les moyens
de se nourrir convenablement. Il ils
nourrissent ils se nourrissent de cette
de ces pesticides. Vous savez que je
j'ouvre une parenthèse que dans les pays
industrialisés sur l'OSCD qui se font
les pays industrialisés sont regroupé
dans cette organisation de l'OSCD 38
États membres
et l'OCD a fait un rapport qui dit que
chaque membre de ces chaque habitant de
France de Suisse et cetera absorbe par
an 5 L de pesticides. 5 L de pesticides.
le glyphosate que l'Union européenne
sous pression du lobby agrochimique
continue à admettre sur ce continent par
exemple et bien chacun de nous absorbe
par an 5 L de pesticides du fait de la
nourriture qui est qui est euh
contaminé
qui est totalement contaminé. Alors
on prend 5 g de plastique aussi par
semaine par éti
Oui. Non mais c'est c'est quand même
assz bon.
J'ai j'ai d'autres questions à suivre ?
Oui, mais laisse laisse-moi
dis-moi.
Non, non, non, non, continue.
Non, c'est
bah c'est le capitalisme, la
maximalisation de profit comme stratégie
unique. Donc ce capitalisme, il faut le
détruire. C'est
Est-ce que tu as un avis sur la crise au
Venezuela ?
Vénézuela ?
Et comment ? Et comment ? Comment ?
Alors le VSU la vit maintenant les
sanctions, le sabotage économique du de
l'empire américain,
le blocus financier alimentaire médical
comme le Chili
en septembre euh 73.
À cette époque, c'était Kissigner,
secret d'État et Nixon, non conseiller,
chef du conseil de sécurité nationale et
Nixon président. Aujourd'hui, c'est
Trump président et Bolton président du
conseil de sécurité nationale.
Au Chili,
ils ont réussi à étouffer, à liquider, à
assassiner le le président
démocratiquement élu. Salvador aîné le
11 septembre 73 73
73 73 a installé
une dicte pour 20 ans une dictature
fasciste effroyable
avec Pinochet surtout le général
mercenaire qui savaient eux-mêmes formé
dans la zone américaine du de Panama.
Il voulait le cuivre et il voulait
étouffer l'exemple rayonnant qui était
la démocratie gilienne par ces réformes
sociales pour le continent euh pour le
pour pour tout le continent. Même chose
maintenant
euh Hugo Chavez a été élu pour la
première fois président de la République
du Venezuela en 99. 99. Il est assassiné
le en 13 2013. Les les médecins cubains
sont absolument formels. On lui a
inoculer une forme de cancer euh tout à
fait inconnu et dévastateur. Il en est
mort. Son vice-président est devenu
président.
Nicolas Maduro qui qui est là. Ce que
les Américains veulent c'est le pétrole
parce que les plus grandes réserves
pétrolières du monde avant l'Arabie
Saoudite sont au Venezuela. ce que Trump
c'est le pétrole du monde. Et ce qu'il
faut étouffer, liquider, c'est le
rayonnement à travers tout le continent
de de l'exemple des réformes sociales du
Venezuela.
J'ai quand même beaucoup de corruption
au Vénzuela.
Attends, je donne un seul exemple mais
mais vraiment ce que j'ai vécu, je peux
parler que de ce que ce que j'ai vécu
en 2000. Je suis mené d'être nommé euh
rapporteur spécial, le premier
rapporteur spécial pour le droit à
l'alimentation. Chavz, c'était au
pouvoir depuis un an. Il a écrit à
Kofianan, il a dit "Je prépare une
campagne pour l'éradication de la fin."
Parce qu'avant son arrivée au pouvoir,
35,2 % des Vénzuéliens
payés infiniment riche par le pétrole
était en permanence gravement
sous-alimenté et il voulait s'attaquer à
la sous-alimentation, à toutes les
maladies de la sous-alimentation. à la
fin Confian m'a mobilisé m'a exigé que
j'aille j'ai mo enfin il y a le
collaborateur qui font un travail
magnifique qu'il faudrait qui m'ont
accompagné évidemment et Flores donc on
parlait présidentiel
des nuits des jours entiers j'ai
travaillé pas avec j'avais oui bien sûr
je l'ai vu plusieurs fois avec ses
collaborateurs les plus proches
dans ce plan Hambreero Hambreero
Au moment où il était assassiné en 2013,
la fin, la sous-limentation, c'est les
chiffres l'ONU ont disparu du Venezuela.
ont disparu du Venezuela.
En 12 ans, la fin a été éradiquée par
Hugo Chaves, enfin par les par le plan,
par les mesures
par la ronde pétrolière.
Oui, mais qui était investi ensuite dans
des magasins populaires, investi dans
des cliniques de réhabilitation et de
réanimation
dans la réforme agréaire et cetera. La
fin a disparu en 12 ans au Venezuela.
Alors que cet exemple là gêne les
Américains, mobilise
comme exemple, comme rayonnement
exemplaire les peuples d'Amérique latine
et fait que un Trump veut écraser le
Venezuela après avoir liquidé enfin
après que les Américains liquid
physiquement Chavz parce que Maduro bon
il n'a pas Chav c'est un magnifique il
est joyeux plein de vie et puis un
orateur
incroyable. Il y avait toujours la
vareuse toujours militaire et il y avait
la constitution
un livret bleu dans sa ici dans son dans
sa poche et chaque fois que on doutait
un peu disait on peu ah la constitution
dit c'est la constitution dit il faut
assurer le bonheur du peuple là article
2 3 un type magnifique bon maduro est un
pas un autodidacte comme comme j'avais
c'est
euh originaellement un chauffeur
d'autobus, un syndicaliste très honnête,
très bien, mais sans évidemment le
charisme de Fidè, de Mandela, de Sancara
ou de Chavis. Mais l'attaque qui se fait
contre le Vénuel là maintenant
est exactement la réédition la réédition
de l'agression portée contre le Chili en
1973.
Et ce qui est lamentable, c'est la
diffamation de la pressure européenne
effrayant contre le contre les réformes
de Chaves, qui a sorti de la misère 9
millions de citoyens et citoyennes du
Vénzuel.
J'invite nos auditeurs à à écouter sur
internet, très facile à trouver le
dernier discours de Salvador Aliend
diffusé à la radio. Ça dure 6 minutes
21, vous avez trouvé ça facilement. Euh
qu'est-ce que tu penses des Black Block
?
Black Block, c'est ces groupes
qui s la violence dans les cortèges des
gilets jaunes. Moi je trouve c'est soit
la police les manipule, ce qui est tout
à fait possible à ce que certains de mes
amis pensent.
Euh soit simplement c'est une stratégie
tout à fait ridicule parce détruire euh
des vitrine de commerçants ou brûler des
voitures ou attaquer les policiers
attaquer physiquement des policiers
politiquement contre-productif
moralement inacceptable et contre l'état
de droit. C'est tout
que la révolution, que le la destruction
du capitalisme et le passage à un monde
nouveau ne peut pas probablement se
faire sans violence parce que l'histoire
nous apprend qu'aucune oligarchie
aussi planétaire, puissante, informée
qu'elle soit renonce à ses privilèges et
ses tout-puissances, à sa tout-puissance
pacifiquement. C'est l'histoire qui nous
l'apprend. et que peut-être dans le
moment
euh paroxistique de la lutte classe,
l'incarnation,
le peuple se lève, l'ancien ordre
s'effondre, un nouvel ordre né dans ses
ruines, qu'à ce moment-là, il aurait
besoin d'une contreviolence
révolutionnaire comme presque toujours
dans l'histoire quand un monde a su a
succéder à l'autre.
Ça me semble probable. Si on peut
l'éviter, tant mieux. Si on peut
l'éviter, tant mieux. Un un point de vue
sur l'anarchie
magnifique. Celle d'attaire. Les
anarchistes sont les le sel et le
malentendu. En 1700 en en 1871
entre Boni et Marx, donc la sortie des
anarchistes et libertaires de la
première internationale au congrès de
Saint-Timier. Bah c'était à mon avis une
catastrophe. C'est une une totale
une un total malentendu. Et ensuite le
régime de Lénine a poursuivi écrasé les
anarchistes.
Euh
c'est inadmissible. C'est inadmissible
puisque les anarchistes qui veulent
mettre fin pas conquérir le pouvoir
d'art mais mettre fin à l'État
immédiatement, fin à toute contrainte
immédiatement et qui ont vécu qui ont
montré ce que pouvait être le communisme
une seule fois dans l'histoire de des
hommes. mars mai euh commune de Paris
71 1871
après 3 mois la commune de Paris a été
écrassé pendant 3 mois le socialisme
libertaire
la sociée anarchiste a vécu et a montré
que c'était possible de mettre fin à la
contrainte entre hommes et femme entre
génération entre patrons et ouvriers
mettre fin et créer et
et créer cette société dont chacun rêve
de solidarité, de complémentaralité,
de
de complémentarité,
de réciprocité. Les hommes sont pas
égaux évidemment, vous êtes forts,
d'autres sont faibles physiquement, l'un
et a un tempérament inventif, créatif de
de bien symbolique et cetera et cetera.
L'autre est un grand orateur. Un autre
n'a pas ces dons-là. L'égalité entre les
hommes, les femmes, les êtres humains,
ça n'existe pas. Mais ce que nous
pouvons créer, nous devons créer. Ce que
les anarchistes ont voulu créer et que
nous devons créer, c'est des rapports de
solidarité, des rapports de
complémentarité
et des rapports de réciprocité. De
réciprocité. dans le manifeste, il y a
un magnifique phrase finale où il dit de
chacun selon ses capacités, pour chacun
selon ses besoins. C'est le monde que je
veux et que veulent des millions d'êtres
humains.
Un mot un mot sur Thomas Sankara.
Magnifique. Ah oui, je la Thomas
Sankara, je l'ai je l'ai bien connu
hein, vraiment.
C'est 83 87. Il a été assassiné en
octobre 87 en France.
Attends, je viens. Je veux pas d'un
nouveau procès. Je veux survivre au
conseil des droits de l'homme. Ça je
Mais
il y a en 83 quelque chose. Noël 83 un
truc incroyable s'est passé. Enfin, j'ai
vacances universitaire professeur
le téléphone sonne dans le petit village
près de Genève où j'habitais à l'époque
Joué. Maintenant, j'habite à Russin, là
où la Suisse se termine enfin, là où le
ronde quitte la Suisse.
Téléphone. Ici le capitaine Sankara.
Professeur Cyclair, ici le capitaine
Sankara.
Il faut que je vous vois, faut venir
nous voir avocat de goût. Je vais vous
faire apporter le billet et cetera. Je
dis écoutez, c'est des vacances de Noël,
je suis dans ma famille. La famille
vient avec vous. Vi avec vous. Alors
moi, j'aime pas beaucoup les militaires.
Alors, Capitaine Sankara, capitaine me
disait rien. Euh
Sankara, ça me disait rien non plus. Ça
me disait rien non plus. Euh
les vacances et il m'a ensuite
convaincu, il m'a dit "Mais j'ai lu
sociologie de la Nouvelle-Afrique
en prison, il faut que je vous parle."
Et finalement, j'ai dit oui enfin par
curiosité et de Paris parce qu'il y
avait pas de consultan de je en suisse
quelqu'un de l'ambassade à Paris est
venu et m'a apporté les trois billets.
mon fils enfin bon m'a apporté et on est
parti et là on m'a cherché à l'aéroport
et m' envoyé à l'entente dans ces dans
cet enclos il y a les les maisons
d'autres et cetera et cetera et il y
avait les quatre révolutionnaires qui
avaient pris le pouvoir qui venaient
prendre le pouvoir Thomas Sankara Songo
Lingani et Camboré les les quatre les
quatre jeunes officiers les quatre
jeunes officiers qui étaient
Et c'est là où on a commencé à discuter
et je suis revenu plusieurs fois
évidemment plusieurs fois
et si je voulais dire si je vous dis
encore une anecdote mais qui montre la
fin de
on n'est jamais amis avec le chef d'état
je reste un intellectuel
critique et cetera mais enfin c'était
c'est un homme magnifique magnifique. Il
nous manque beaucoup en ce moment
ici en Afrique, il manque mais
incroyablement
La dernière fois que je l'ai vu, c'était
en 87 en septembre 87 en Éthiopie
à la proclamation de la nouvelle
constitution éthiopienne
et où j'ai été invité avec ma femme, une
autre femme, nouvelle femme, nouvelle
passion, pas bref, les deux sont
magnifiques
Et
on était dans les tribunes, c'était dans
l'Africa hall si vous connaissez sap.
C'était le siège de l'Union africaine,
l'Africa hall tout en haut là on était
là les invités et en bas il y avait
Thomas et ses gardes enfin là où étit
les chefs d'état. Et tout à coup Thomas
se retourne et il me voit, il m'envoie
un de ses adjoints pour fixer
rendez-vous le soir même dans la villa
où il était au Guillaum. Nous on était
au guantel et puis lui il était envia
une des villes des chefs d'état.
Et on discute
c'est incroyable c'est le mobilier russe
des des trucs massifs des tables basses
des des fauteuil on avait mal au dos et
cetera. Enfin, on était assis dans ces
dans ce mobilier
et tout à coup, je lui dis enfin quelque
chose, j'ai dit euh euh c'est
l'anniversaire de la mort du Tevara.
L'anniversaire de la mort du Tkevara
euh le 7 octobre
à 67, c'est les 20 ans, c'est les 20
ans, on parle en 87 làbas, c'est les 20
ans euh 7 octobre 80 euh 67. la mort
l'assassinat du Cheevara et Thomas comme
il est tout de suite réagi mais c'est
fondable il faut il faut absolument
qu'on aille faire une qu'on qu'on
organise dans le stade Wagadou quand
qu'on rentre meeting qu'on fasse un
meeting pour le souvenir du CH pour
honorer le T est-ce que vous pouvez
m'écrire tout ce que vous savez sur le
Che parce qu'il savait que j'avais
rencontré le Tout ce que il faudrait
qu'on en parle du T un moment euh
Est-ce que vous pourriez écrire ce que
vous savez du
bon et je me suis agenouillé devant
cette table basse russe ce mobilier fré
et j'ai j'ai rempli à la main stylo des
feuilles et des feuilles tout ce que je
savais du comment pourquoi et c
il le prend mon papier et regarde et dit
il est mort à 38 ans. 38 ans assassiné.
J'ai dit oui. Et il dit comme une
prémonition, est-ce que j'arriverai à 38
ans ?
Il a été assassiné 1 mois après, à 37
ans et 8 mois. À 37 ans et 8 mois. C'est
la t fois que je l'ai vu.
Avant avant que tu nous parles du je
viens de recevoir une question que j'ai
pas étudié plus en détail. Ça te parle
le rapport bergier ? Ah oui, bien sûr.
Alors raconte-moi ce que c'est le
rapport bergier. Un rapport officiel de
la confédération déposée à l'ONU qui
explique que la Suisse intervenant à de
la culture là. Non,
je t'écoute.
Berier est un professeur d'histoire, un
de mes collègues à l'université puis
ensuite à l'École polytechnique fédérale
et ça portait
sur
deux crimes commis
par les dirigeants les soit éliteshiques
durant la 2è guerre mondiale.
Les deux crimes étaient les suivants.
D'une part, Hitler
l' des juifs. Non, attends
je là où tu as raison mais euh le lavage
noir Hitler en 39 était au bout. Le
rarement lui a coûté tellement de fric
qu'il n'avait plus d'argent. il a
déclenché la 2è guerre mondiale et dans
11 pays, il a saisi les réserves tor
parce que c'était l'époque où les
banques centrales avaient les réserves
où toutes les monnaies étaient côté euh
sur l'or.
Or, à la Banque de France, à la Banque
de Bruxelles euh et cetera, toute cette
or été identifiée avec des numéros et
marqué par le signe national. Donc on
pouvait pas l'utiliser sur le marché
mondial. on y devait acheter du chrome,
du nickel et cetera, des des matériaux
des matières premières stratégiques pour
son armement.
Donc il a fait un accord avec la Banque
Nationale Suisse et l'oligarchie
bancaire ettique pour que cette or volée
soit amené deux fois par mois par une
colonne de camion qui entr en Suisse à
balle gardé par des SS en armes amené à
Berne à la Banque nationale pour être
refondu.
Et cet or volé dans 11 pays et chez des
privés aussi, il y avait des commandants
SS qui qui faisaient le pillage chez les
privés.
Cet or inventable était refondu par la
Banque Nationale,
marqué par la croix Elvitique et par les
nouveaux numéros et renvoyé à Berlin
après déduction d'une massive
commission. C'est là le fondement de la
richesse astronomique des banques
suisses. C'est là à ce moment-là
renvoyé à Berlin et Berlin pouvait
utiliser cet or marqué par la Croix
Suisse, donc tout à fait insoupçonnable
pour acheter dans le monde entier les
matières premières stratégiques dont tu
avait besoin l'armée allemande. Ça c'est
le premier problème. Le deuxième crime
commis par les dirigeants c'était
le
l'occultation des flui
est venu au pouvoir en janvier 33.
L'Allemagne avait beaucoup de
communautés
en général assez riches ou des
industries et cetera. des commerces
juifs.
Euh les juifs d'Allemagne savaient
l'antisémitisme, l'horreur que même s'il
pouvait pas prévoir
prévoir le le crime absolu qu'était les
camps d'extermination. Mais à juste
titre et d'une façon tout à fait
compréhensive, beaucoup
d'entreprises ou de familles juives ont
évacuer leur argent, leur économie, leur
épanne dans les banques suisses. Dans
les banques suisses et c'est là
d'ailleurs où le secret bancaire est né.
C'est là parce queappo a infiltré deux
banques à balle. Il y a eu un process
toute carte et
13 personnes ont été fusilé donc tous
suivent. Alors,
il y a donc des fortunes juives qui se
sont constituées
pour des raisons tout à fait
fortune suisse
dans des banques suisses dans des
banques suisses.
L'horreur est absolue est arrivée avec
les camps d'extermination avec
l'holocauste.
Les banquiers suisses se sont dit tout
le monde est mort, personne va nous
demander cet argent et l'ont transféré
dans ce qu'on appelle les réserves
silencieuse des banques.
Or,
en, 1991,
l'Union Soviétique a implosé en août et
les dernière communauté totalement
intacte était évidemment à l'est.
juif et tes fils, tes tes filles et
cetera de ces communautés juives de
l'est venu au quichet au crédit suisse
là-bas l'USBS et cetou dans la banque
privée et on dit je sais que mon
grand-père ou mon père ou ma mère ma
grand-mère et cetera, mon oncle avait un
dépôt chez vous euh je sais qu'il a
correspond et cetera et cetera qu'il a
cet argent chez vous s'il vous plaît
rendez-le moi et le fonctionnalité le
cliché le suisse conforme à la loi
d'ailleurs, pas par méchanceté conforme
à la loi suisse qui dit "Montrez-moi le
certificat de décès."
Le certificat de décès pour que je sache
que vous êtes l'héritier unique et
cetera. Alors le le leandeur juif disait
"Mais à Trblin, Soubora au Suisse, il
n'avait pas de certificat de décès sur
quoi le fonctionnaire suisse disait
"Alors là, je peux rien faire pour vous,
repartez.
Et ce scandale s'est prolongé jusqu'au
moment où le gouvernement d'Israël a
confié une représentation collective au
congrès juif mondial. On dit au congrès
juif mondial. Mettez fin à ce scandale.
Forcez les banques suisses de restituer
ces milliards et ces milliards de de
francs de dollars et cetera de fonds
juifs qu'ils ont eux empochés. empoucher
et comme le congrès juif mondial était
très lié au parti démocrate, c'était
Clinton à l'époque
et bien il y a une pression formidable
dans les différents États américains,
dans les différents parlements locaux
américains même au conseil municipal de
New York qui a dit ou bien les fran
suisses payent ou bien ils sont exclus
des paiements du dollar ou de ou d'un
siège quelconque à la bourse de Chicago
de de New York.
au stock exchange
et cetera et cetera et la pression était
telle que finalement les banques suisse
ont dû signer un accord
où une tout petite fraction une toute
petite fraction de cet argent volé a été
restitué
partie et là pour votre
interrogateur le interrogatrice je sais
pas
interrogateur
interrogateur là il y a eu un petit
réveil
euh dans la classe dirigeante petit ça
passait tout de suite après maintenant
il parle de chantage les juifs nous ont
mis sous chantage. C'était on a mandaté
ce professeur d'histoire et quelquesuns
de ses collègues à faire un rapport sur
les deux crimes sur les deux crimes qui
ont confirmé évidemment totalement ce
que je viens de vous de vous de vous
dire. Et là, le conseil fédéral,
gouvernement suisse a fait des choses
extraordinaires
euh pour les calministes. C'est excusé
publiquement.
Bon,
on on arrive à la à la fin de notre
interview.
C'est dommage.
Et euh on pourrait rester un peu mais
euh il fall faut parler du
ouis. On parle du
allez.
parce que je lui dois tellement de
choses.
J'étais jeune quand j'étais jeune il y a
200 ans. J'étais
au groupe Clarté au jeunesse communiste
français quand j'étais
là et une des activités de clarté enfin
du qui a été dissous ensuite dans la
guerre d'Algérie
par le PC dans ce dans la jeunesse
universitaire communiste. On faisait des
brigades de solidarité lors de la
récolte de la canne à sucre en juillet à
à Cuba. Ce qui embêtait plus les Cubains
que les les réluissaient parce coup la
canne
c'est extraordinairement difficile.
C'est extraordinaire difficile. Le soir
au habana libre dans ce Hilton le long
des sur des longs long tables de bois
dans les sous-sols le ha de Santa Maria
Armando Hard fidèle et cetera venez
discuter avec nous avec les jeunes
européens notamment français discuter
politique discuter de la révolution et
cetera
et en avril 1964
j'étais déjà de retour du Congo
Euh quand Claré a été dissous, j'ai dû
quitter Paris, je suis allé comme petit
fonctionnaire au Congo après
l'assassinat de Lomba, j'étais de retour
à Genève. Je reçois un coup de téléphone
de Laavane d'un des dirigeants euh
cubains, pas un des grands mais un des
moyens
qui me demandait qui me disait une
grande délégation qui arrivé qui va
arriver au palais des nations à l'ONU à
Gennev. pour la première conférence
mondiale du sucre qui était essentielle
à l'époque plus maintenant pour Cuba
puisque 80 % des devises à l'époque
venait du sucre. On a ni consulat ni
ambassade chez toi. Peux-tu nous aider
pour organiser un peu l'infrastructure,
les transports, les hôtels et cetera ?
avec quelques amis à mieux amis. J'avais
fait ça. La délégation est arrivée.
Chef de la délégation TK Vara ministre
de de l'industrie et je suis devenu son
chauffeur
pendant 12 jours, son chauffeur
personnel dans ma vieille
euh Maurice, un petit mini Maurice
d'occasion noire. Et je l'ai j'étais
avec lui tous les jours et souvent très
très tard dans la nuit. Dimanche on
allait à Chamoni voulait voir Chamoni
Montblanc et cetera. Il parlait
parfaitement le français. Moi je parlais
très très mal l'Espagnon. Maintenant ça
va mieux à l'époque lui parce que
Tonasia sa mère était très très
francophile, il parlait parfaitement le
français. Il y a d'ailleurs des
interviews de la télévision suisse
romante que j'ai amené ensuite aux
archives de Tevala à Donalida euh où le
T répond en français parfaitement au
journalistes. Bref, et la la dernière
nuit la dernière nuit que je savais que
le lendemain il partait de nouveau par
le chemin de fer suric Munich Brac parce
que c'était la seule ligne de Hercubana
de Prag à Lavane à l'époque. J'ai pris
tout mon courage dans mes mains et j'ai
dit commandant je vais aller avec vous.
J'ai dit ils avaient encore la vareuse
vert olive le beret noir avec le
l'étoile
dorée du commandant le die était
contrairement à Fidèle qui était d'une
chaleur incroyable dit mais comment va
ton fils ? quand tu l'as pas amené et
cetera et ça le tien était froid,
ironique mais incroyablement intelligent
curieux tout le temps des questions et
cetera. Bon il m'a appelé à la fenêtre
sur la colline au grand ça connais où
était l'hôtel on voyait la baie de
Genève la nuit illuminée par les
réclames bancaires, des bijoutiers, des
assureurs et cetera. Je je dit, il m'a
dit "Tu vois, tu vois cette ville, c'est
là que tu es né, c'est là le cerveau du
monstre, c'est là que tu dois te
battre." Et il s'est retourné
froidement, il est parti. Moi, j'ai été
détruit sur place. Évidemment, je
pensais qu'il me prenait pour un petit
bourgeois inutile, ce qui était
probablement le cas. ce qui était
probablement le cas,
mais je lui dois ma vie et je lui dois
la stratégie de la subversion, de
l'intégration subversive que j'applique
depuis lors la vie d'abord, j'étais
objectifur de conscience,
j'ai jamais fait de service militaire
enfin quelques jours et puis après
j'étais
j'étais emprisonné. Euh j'ai été nul
militairement. Je serai ici m'avait dit
viens avec nous. Je serai depuis très
très longtemps enterré euh dans un dans
une fausse commune du Venezuela du du
Guemala
ou de Bolivie, c'est certain. Il m'a
sauvé la vie et il m'a montré le chemin
de la subvers de l'intégration
subversive. entrer dans les
institutions,
utiliser la force, tenter d'utiliser la
force de ces institutions pour ses
propres buts. Boukar
que Tch a souvent a souvent cité
Boukarin qui a été fusié par par Stalin
Boukarin a dit les révolutionnaires sont
des opportunistes qui ont des principes
et depuis lors l'intégration subversive
j'essaie de la pratiquer d'abord à
l'université
ensuite au Parlement ethique maintenant
aux Nations Unies et c'est le T qui m'a
pris cette stratégie je sais pas si est
efficace en tout cas si la seule qui
pour moi et
que je peux concrétisser, c'est la seule
stratégie, l'intégration subversif.
Alors, un conseil un conseil de lecture,
trois livres à conseiller à la
communauté.
Est-ce que je serais assez orgueilleux
pour citer mon propre livre ?
Alors, un seul sur les trois.
Un seul.
Premier livre, le capitalisme expliqué à
ma petite fille en espérant qu'il
enverra
la fin. Et cette fin, elle viendra tout
de suite.
Deux autres
de l'autre livre, ça va être
les misérables Victor Hugo. Vraiment, je
dis ça parce que je l'ai relis très très
souvent.
Et le troisème
c'est incroyable de devoir choisir dans
tout ce que j'aime. C'est dur.
Ah ben
les discours collectés de Jean Jo
qui n'est pas une question qui est
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, quelque chose
d'impérissable sur internet.
Insurgez-vous, il n'y a pas de vous avez
la chance puisque vous écoutez cette
émission de vivre en démocratie.
Et Volter a dit la liberté est l'unique
bien qui ne su quand on si on ne
l'utilise pas. Si on ne l'utilise pas.
Combattre l'ennemi, connaître l'ennemi
si vous êtes en étude et cetera.
connaître l'ennemi, faire les meilleures
études possibles, connaître le plus de
choses de ce monde, démasquer
l'oppresseur, détruire euh détruire
l'obscurantisme, ce néolibéralisme
obscurantiste qui essaie de priver
l'homme de sa propre histoire et qui
sert encore malheureusement de théorie
de légitimité
pour la dictature mondiale des
oligarchies du capital financier
globalisé. connaître l'ennemi et ensuite
tout faire solidairement là où vous
pouvez pour détruire cet ennemi, pour
combattre cet ennemi, être digne des
privilèges incroyables qui sont les
nôtres, vivant en démocratie, vivant
librement, vivant toute connaissance de
cause vivant bien nourri,
capable de reçoir des émissions comme
celle-là.
Bah ça crée des privilèges incroyables
qui nous forcent qui nous forc
ne pas sortir de l'histoire de ne pas se
laisser paralyser de ne pas se laisser
influencer
mais se battre
Jean Zigler merci
merci à Oh.
[Musique]